Recording Shazamm bitches.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
What's going on with my mic?
I'm just suggesting it was a really high to just main brown vibrant.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link and enter in the code named
Brogan,
you will get 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
The only one that I've ever heard of that's even remotely effective.
I stand behind it and Nick Thune,
it's a solid product side.
Stand in it.
I'll give you one if you want one.
Do you want one?
Okay.
Ask Solent nick doing and our guests now has a free flashlights because there's
this advertisement.
Is it just a,
just one of those regular flashlights?
Well,
it looks like a flashlight and then you open the top and there's a rubber vagina
and he goes,
Oh,
you've never seen one?
I've heard of him.
I've seen,
I can't believe you got this phone up.
You're failing in one as it could've been,
you know,
and the other ones do.
You have a butthole one over here
and they didn't do it for real.
Did they look different?
Yeah,
the butthole one.
It looks like a button.
It looks like a little usually looks pretty similar to,
it's really kind of disturbing.
It's just that I dunno man.
In two guys deciding about only wanting the bud hall,
you know,
like if you had to choose,
you don't want the vagina.
It's just people for your masturbation device.
I mean did the fact that you needed to look like a vagina at all?
You just need it to feel good.
I mean,
what do you just compartmentalizing your visual cortex so you only see the part
that's attached your Dick's.
It looks like a rubber pussy.
You don't use your brain and go,
why would it rubber pussy being a pleasant to,
what am I doing?
What am I come on,
man.
You know what they should do?
They should do.
I try fucked up flashlight where it's like,
it's like,
it looks like a,
you know,
a Hanukkah tree or whatever where it's three different flashlights all attached
to one handle.
Oh.
So you get like I'm in Nordic,
switch gears to a mouth every now and then.
Yeah.
And then when you hold it would actually look,
feel like a plastic girls.
But two when you're fucking like the middle one.
So is there a mouth one?
Yes.
Yeah.
Even like vampire mouth ones?
Like their fags and shit.
Did they have Zombie resembles teeth?
Like yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well it's not hard.
No,
just the same.
The same when it worked for me then yeah,
you like teeth.
Anything like a little suffering.
Huge teeth.
Little Penguins.
Your pleasure.
It's nice to let you know you're alive anyway.
Did most girls drag it?
Their teeth on your Dick?
Like is that new?
Is that common?
Cause it seems like it happens to me a lot.
And then I was thinking,
now I'm thinking maybe I just have a fat dick.
Whoa.
And it like,
cause like they always drag a whole joke.
No,
there's girls are angry with you.
They're trying to punish you.
They just can't believe they're actually sucking your Dick.
So you
chew on a little bit.
I think that's something normal to do that is you've had that happen to them.
Well,
no.
It just seems like it's something that would happen,
but a lot like 99% at a time.
Maybe you date these little mild bitches,
right?
Yeah,
man.
Maybe that's one of the things I look for in a girl's face were announced.
We're also sponsored by Onnit.
Dot.
O.
N.
N I t.
Makers have such wonderful supplements as Alpha brain.
I take it all the time.
I'm on it right now.
That's what makes my conversations flow so smoothly.
Does it work?
Yeah,
it does work.
for sure.
Absolutely.
Works with me.
There's people who say it doesn't doe.
Everybody's different.
Some people are allergic to peanuts.
You know,
the,
the human body is not,
it's not equal.
Everybody doesn't get the same package,
you know,
so,
which is unfortunate.
Yeah,
it is.
Yeah.
I mean,
some be a lot easier die if they fucking,
you know,
eat certain foods that you love.
That's crazy.
Right?
It's really bizarre.
The human body is a very strange animal.
Whatever the fucking has these,
these are nutrients essentially that enhance cognitive function and uh,
it's all online.
You can,
there's a page that was written by a medical editor of the science behind Alpha
brain,
and we're trying to clarify that up as much as possible and be as honest about
the supplement as possible.
It's not limitless.
It's not going to make you a super genius,
but I think it makes my brain work better.
And it,
these nootropics are stuff that are in it.
You can find them online.
I encourage people,
if you don't want to buy our shit,
just go find the ingredients that we have on line and make your own,
go,
go buy the stuff wholesale.
You know,
you'll save some money for sure if you don't want it to get a science degree.
If you're in it.
Yeah,
it's just start manufacturing on equipment.
lab coats or if you're not wearing that cup,
do not try and make your own.
We have a bunch of different stuff.
We have Alpha brain,
we have the southern less controversial things like new mood,
which is a five HTP and the El Tryptofan enhancer send Burt crisis.
None of that shit back and forth.
He was like an ice skating a lot that the fan,
it'll trip to fans.
I was like a ice skating.
He sounds like he's more Spanish than I skating.
Beautiful trip to Penn and into it really.
And do a triple cows.
Oh Gosh.
She just did a back to back shroom tech sport,
which is um,
a quarter sibs,
mushroom supplement and the quarter subs.
Mushrooms is,
it's a weird kind of an energy that it gives you.
It's really fun.
It's not,
not like coffee.
It's like if you,
if you're in shape,
if you're not a person works out.
I'd say skip this one.
This is really not for you.
But if you're one of those people that works out really hard,
which is shit gives you great.
And I really like guns and animal looking at me.
Savage,
you don't get that beer just sitting around the house.
You think you think any normal person can wear Carhartt vest?
Yeah,
man.
With a white t shirt.
He's an animal.
Bam.
Anyway,
go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the Alpha brain link.
Enter in the code name rug and get 10% off or not the end of commercials.
Dunes in the house.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we're going to get the party started
all day.
That's a little wake up.
Come in and hot right there.
Wake up.
It's those,
some of them drums,
man fires up the synopsis.
Young Nick was at Drummond,
right,
right
there.
Uh,
Brian to find people at app out there that forces and drummed Brian Garageband
that it's actually now I actually have a band where we were called garage band.
Then they came out with that whole software and we got,
oh,
that's brutal.
Screwed.
Yeah.
Never called electronic.
Japan's amazing.
I mean,
Brian,
you don't have any musical background,
right?
I make songs all the time,
but the problem is that,
you know what I'm saying?
I mean,
you never went to school for it,
anything,
right?
Yeah.
But after a while you start hearing the same like melodies and like commercial
and you just figured out how to use the software and you just started fucking
around and just how to read music.
No,
no,
no.
It's just that was just a combination of using different loops and then changing
the sounds of the loops.
And then don't say your secrets.
You know,
dude,
I've been,
I've been tripped out since we were a at your place,
at your new studio and we were talking about that nine year old kid or what does
he,
12 year old kid that is written five symphonies.
He and this guy,
he was walking on the street how he's two years old.
He was writing music.
Kid was two years old.
He was drawing pictures of Cellos and writing music.
I don't even think it was two years old.
Like these were like drawings and crayons and say how he's 10 now.
Yeah.
Well now I think he's 12 or what is that?
Is that the truth?
Or is a 20 now?
Maybe this is an older,
I feel like he's 20 now and I feel like they said he'd been studying in Europe,
so who knows how good he is or if he's gone completely bonkers.
Yeah.
He's probably in his video,
this poor kid was walking down the street and he was like skipping and,
and like making music at the same time.
Like so,
so happy and like just going happy.
Yeah.
I mean I want,
I said poor kid.
I mean,
I just mean because what a burden to have that kind of genius,
you know,
overflowing literally over whelming you,
I mean,
you can't say that everybody is the same.
When there's people like that that exists.
It's prime primes,
the dust skydeck and what if you,
you know,
you get older,
could we got them and you know,
you peaked at seven,
you know,
like what if that would,
if that was the best possible,
then that would be a tough thing to deal with.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
Because usually people peak in that early part of their career when it comes to
creativity,
I think.
Yeah.
Well,
usually that's when you're the most pure and your intentions,
you know,
you,
you really are focused.
You want that prize.
And then what happens?
The trappings of fame set in and guys get fat,
Rock Stars get fat and it alters your mood.
It alters your mindset.
Like when I had a day job or when I was working in the beginning and that get
created,
this create,
you know,
like it made me think on my feet more and want to stop doing that.
You know?
And then once you get,
you go through that phase of where the creativity changes comes from a different
place.
Yeah.
Once you also know what stand up really is,
you know?
I mean,
I feel like it takes years to figure out what you're actually doing up there.
Yeah.
But if this kid just starts off never doing anything about that,
yeah.
He's gone up.
She retired at 14 five symphonies.
I mean,
it was amazing.
And you know,
and he was playing his music.
It was,
I don't know,
classical music for,
well,
I'm not really a fan,
but,
uh,
it,
it was,
it sounded amazing.
You know,
I have a joke where I say this kid would,
could use probably literally right before I play a song and I say is the first
song I ever wrote.
And the first song I ever heard,
I didn't want any influences like that.
That could be that kids,
he never heard a song.
He just started making it.
It's crushing.
Imagine it's fucking crazy.
That's what a amazing ability.
She's got to know.
Is he good looking?
Imagine if he has a giant hug to at 12 that's how it,
that's how my friends,
that's all.
Imagine that for a sec.
Uber,
munch.
Do you know Jonathan Daniel Brown?
See one of the kids from Tim Allen Shell.
Now.
I know we've talked about it,
but it was it more than two names.
Like what's going on.
I didn't always think that's him.
Yeah,
he's a,
he's up Jonathan Taylor,
Thomas Plato of,
of celebrity volleyball game once,
a long time ago.
And,
uh,
I got to see like that guy that Jonathan Taylor Thomas was on the Tim Allen show
right when he was like,
he was young then,
you know,
he was probably like,
I was young too.
I was like in my early,
maybe mid twenties but he was a younger than me.
I think he was like a young teenager and he was really famous,
you know,
that the show is really popular and it was so weird out how the kid was,
I was like,
you,
he was like hit all this like crazy like confidence and all this like,
you know,
exuberance that comes from being a fucking television star before you've ever
even evolved as a human being and to be that cute.
Yeah.
To be cute and to be on just giant hit show.
And I always remember thinking this because I'm,
I have this thing where I do where if,
especially when I meet someone fucked up,
I put them into my science project folder and I'm like,
well where's this guy going to be in five years and 10 years?
Like what is,
what is,
is his transition to reality?
Going to be like,
cause right now he goes back to reality.
Yeah.
Well you go back to it every now and then and go check in on him.
Yeah,
go,
go and see.
Do you have like a liberal out them,
like a list of people that alarm goes off check on.
I had 2014 most of them you can't really check on too much and most of our girls
are used to date.
My friend has a note in his phone that's like bartender at the Improv.
Dave old guy is well and he has like all the comedy clubs and everywhere.
He just marks their name down by how they look.
And he always goes to that.
I mean just like girl that you think as a manager's assistant,
Olivia,
he just has this list.
It's Pete Holmes.
I mean it's just out you,
you see John Taylor Thomas
on Twitter.
He has a hilarious Twitter,
John Taylor Thomas,
and he's a comedy purists that to who is,
has he ever retweeted me?
Uh,
I'm sure he probably has.
I wonder who that could be.
He often fucks up really,
really Jonathan Taylor Thomas as it verified [inaudible] corporation.
We checked,
we checked the zero five right now if my page is verified,
no it's not.
I'll verify it.
Is it?
Oh,
we'll just take a look at this.
It's absolutely not.
Yes it is.
When did you guys done?
A while ago,
right?
Oh yeah.
Do you have a Wikipedia page also too?
You got anything habit.
It's terrible.
I need to go in there and he's angry.
He's angry.
Someone that Wikipedia is not a Brian Fam.
They probably listened to the podcast.
And if you listen to the podcast,
listen,
it's a very unique dynamic.
You know,
I'm a strong cup of coffee and he blurts in with childish Shit Diet,
right?
This is just what it is.
It's just what it is.
So together it works.
But people get angry sometimes in him.
They get angry at him.
And uh,
I think so
sort of people keep putting stuff up,
dude.
I have to check people all the time,
man.
On the,
especially on the message board,
I've added a few things.
Juniors,
Douchey,
cubic good,
cheers,
attitudes,
Wikipedia.
What did you add that took down?
You got took down.
He could still do backflips why would they take that down?
I don't know.
I did it for so I could reference it in a,
in a like a bid I was going to do that night.
You put it in Wikipedia so that you can do it on TV and then,
cause I was doing the tonight show and I had a bit about them and I wanted this
and I haven't a part of the thing.
I go to Wikipedia,
he does all his own stunts and he's still can do back flips and so I've put them
on and it got taken off before I did the show.
That's hilarious.
When you get set up your own bits,
you can set up your own bits by putting fake shit on someone's Wikipedia.
How would you actually know if you could use it as a couch thing that night and
we'll probably still be up.
Yeah,
totally.
That's a great idea.
How hard is it to edit someone's Wikipedia edit button?
How are they making any money?
Wikipedia make money.
Everyone uses it.
No he doesn't.
He just uses donated.
It's actually pro bono.
Yeah.
Is it a.org?
Yeah,
it is.
Really?
Yeah.
Um,
did you know that the edge,
the edge and new to his lawyers pro bono.
So if they ever break up
pro bono,
I said that at a radio station in Denver that Youtube was playing at the stadium
the next week.
And I went in this guy named uncle nasty and I know that dude,
he's super nice,
but I see these youtube posters all over the place and I go,
hey,
did you see what has happened on Twitter?
There's live.
And he goes,
no,
what?
And I go,
you two broke up.
And he goes,
what?
What are they gonna do?
They're playing next week.
And he's like,
seriously?
Got In.
And then I did the,
yeah,
and let the edges lawyers pro bono.
And he looked at
me and he goes,
oh,
we're going to commercial.
And it guys,
he goes,
yeah,
you can't tell jokes like that.
You,
well you did it.
Just put people into a tailspin.
See these God damn to mania is to see this.
This is
mind of a standup comic.
They were just telling me this trick that they played on Brendan Walsh.
Are you allowed to?
No,
I don't want to.
no,
because then they'll just hope he'll fire back in the late.
He's scared,
but it's funny.
I thought this whole thing was a prank.
I thought you did tell the story,
man.
It's hard to say what I thought because I don't want to say the prank we did on
him because that's a lie,
because he outdid somebody else on a,
in a thing where,
and then you just like,
did he agree with that guy that he wanted that story out?
Why wouldn't you want it?
The story I was telling me,
it's humbling.
He doesn't even,
people would go up to him.
He wouldn't even tell him.
Oh,
and it was a,
you're crazy.
That's a whole area story.
Brendan Walsh,
his whole act,
he talks about doing pranks,
but his buddies doing pranks does wife,
he closes with that bid.
That hilarious.
Bitty done.
Yeah.
And he outdid Chris Banks on it.
Tell the bit,
son,
give it up.
What happened?
Well.
All right.
I knew
no,
because first of all,
start tweeting at him right away.
Our friend before we sell bad Brendan Walsh is fun.
I carious I can't out it.
He's a hilarious comedian.
But Brendan Walsh is a Goddamn trickster.
He's a prankster and he does crazy shit.
Like he made wholefoods signs and put them out with solely,
it was hilarious.
We've got all these people thinking that whole foods was coming to silver lake.
They were all excited.
I heard the rumors from other people.
I got my dog park.
People were like to hear whole foods is coming in.
Yeah,
there's a sign up,
you know,
people for two weeks.
And then did you hear it was a prank?
It was like a major,
why wouldn't wholefoods build one there?
No one.
Exactly smarter.
The Los Angeles Times reached out to them.
There was like everyone reached out to them and they gave uh,
a statement saying we are not planning on building.
So they,
that's like Brendan's joke went that far.
So great.
Well,
so anyway,
Brendon is constantly doing shit like that.
Like playing pranks.
Yeah.
And he pranked me that I,
he,
he pranked.
Um,
he got somebody else to tweet with them.
Congrats to Nick Thune about SNL.
And I'd actually audition for SNL a while before that,
which he didn't know,
you know,
Lacey says,
and uh,
I just started getting tons of emails and people were retweeting it and some
comedy blogs picked it up and I didn't get SNL and all of a sudden I'm getting
eat.
Like just congratulations my dad.
I mean,
it's that easy.
Yeah,
it's,
and,
and it's so easy to spread.
I had to give a statement to somebody saying it was,
I guess he wins if he got,
if people have to give press statements.
Yeah.
He won and,
and wash and he manipulates billboards.
He added himself to like a big,
like that's my favorite blog to a top chef thing.
He took a picture of himself stirring a ball and got it to scale,
to scale.
It was so fun.
It just makes me,
can we just add it into this billboard and you got a job.
I mean,
it's a super small,
but it's still six feet tall,
right?
Yeah.
And he had made and he had a fucking big laminate made me,
he climbed up onto a phone cord and he had like a meeting and I love that guy.
Get a meeting in front of your diet.
They were talking in a room and out of the window there was a billboard and he
had mentioned,
he pointed it out to them in the meeting set,
like setting himself up.
A callback pointed out the billboard.
Then that night snuck out there and added a joke to it.
I don't know what it was.
There was something he said and in the next day they walk out and they like text
him like we just saw.
Brilliant.
That's hilarious.
What a great idea he has that.
He's a,
he's on the edge though because you know,
just kind of day.
I mean,
that's some dangerous stuff.
You can get hurt,
you know when you're climbing up on billboards,
that's scary.
Shit.
Dudes fall off.
Those things.
They die.
Yeah,
but he didn't fall off.
No,
he's still alive,
unfortunately.
He's still out there.
And you can still prank at any moment.
A dude's awesome.
So what'd you do to him?
Oh God.
Well I think it's worth it.
I think it's funny.
Yeah,
it is funny.
It's fucking hilarious.
Go for it.
It's just setting me up to get it even worse.
Listen the way back.
I think he would [inaudible] it's already in motion.
I can't believe you even worried about the dot talking about this is nothing
compared to where you actually did.
Yeah,
you're right.
You're right.
Cause this is more like building up what the guy too.
So,
but yeah,
he needs this them.
So I was waiting to get them back
and we were at a Conan because our friend John Doerr and Rory Scovel work and
um,
do a standup at where Conan,
it's like,
you know,
we messed up,
we actually double booked Comedians,
but they both agreed to come out at the same time.
So they go out and they do like,
it was really funny.
You can Google that,
people that are watching.
But uh,
I went to watch it live and I was hanging out and somebody said that Brennan was
coming,
Walsh.
And I said,
well,
we got to prank him if he's not here yet.
We got,
we all got a band together,
it'll a,
so we figured something out really quickly and put it into motion right away
with the production of Conan involved.
Um,
and when he showed up,
I just said,
hey,
I don't know if I was outside having a cigarette.
And I was like,
if,
I don't know if he talked to JP had been,
he wanted to talk to you.
And he goes,
uh,
you know,
he goes looking for him.
He runs into John Doerr.
John Doerr is like,
you gotta talk to JP.
So he gets up to him and he goes,
I'm actually shit,
I shouldn't say producers' names.
I'm not going to say it again.
[inaudible] going to say it again.
It's live.
So,
you know,
um,
great.
Can you edit that out in the next [inaudible]
oh,
it's on the internet,
Bro.
Dr For parties.
Yeah.
So the person and
involve said,
uh,
hey,
there's a sketch we want you to do.
And he said,
um,
what is it?
And he goes,
well,
you have to shave half your beard and dressed like Harry Potter.
And the part that we messed up because it actually,
it was like we told them that there was money involved.
Um,
he goes,
is their money?
And they said,
yeah,
it pays.
And so they just went right into motion.
Brendan went into a go get his half as beard,
shaved off and makeup and I wanted to go take a picture.
This is how cut,
this is how much the crew there was into it.
I go in and take a picture of him with a half a beard and the guy goes,
no time for pictures.
We got to get them in wardrobe.
Now there's this wardrobe,
guys were running up to wardrobe.
They'd get them in this beautiful Harry Potter outfit
and he comes down to the green room and now it's just waiting.
You know,
all he knows his beard,
Harry Potter,
somebody comes in a producer,
they have him sign a w nine w whatever,
40 w two foot,
the 40 wd forties.
So I mean,
now it's like,
it's obviously real,
there's paperwork involved.
Um,
then this kid comes in and they've got,
we've got people calling him Walter,
this was John Doors idea,
which was probably the funniest part was that,
um,
so was always call him Walter no matter what.
And so people were like,
we're always saying Walter.
And he finally was like responding to Walter because it was such a hassle
telling people his name wasn't Walter.
Um,
so this kid comes in and he's like flipping through these scripts and he's got a
headset on and he's obviously like a pa that just like playing and that wants to
be an actor.
And he goes,
so Walter in here,
and Brendan goes,
yeah,
Walter.
Correct.
Anyone?
Yeah,
he was,
he started correcting people.
Then he stopped.
But they just kill it with the same people.
Can they give you God's Brennan and they wouldn't say anything.
Yes,
but this isn't saying anything.
That was John Doerr.
John Doerr is a genius.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
And so on.
And so I'm now at this point,
Brennan,
you know,
wants to see a script and this kid goes,
can you read cue cards?
And he goes,
yeah,
but I'd like to see a script.
You know,
I want to see what we're doing here.
And,
and he got,
the kid just goes,
okay,
and runs.
So no answer to his question.
Nothing.
Now he knows that he's probably going to have cue cards is even know what the
bid is.
He's not happy at this point.
Like now at this point he's taken the circle glasses off and he's just
not happy.
The show starts,
he knows it's in the first segment.
Conan,
we can see in the TV that Conan's already out doing the monologue and this woman
comes in and she goes,
is there a Walter in here?
And he goes,
yeah.
And she goes,
the Harry Potter sketch has been cut.
Did you see his face when this happened?
Yeah,
we haven't.
We have a video video.
He walked out straight to the producer and he goes,
um,
they just told me this sketch was cut.
And he goes,
well,
I think that's what happens in late night TV.
Did you should edit that and put that cone.
And he goes and he turns around and any,
and he sees me and John Doerr just filming him from behind and just that's
brilliant.
Not happy that he was angry for like,
you know,
initially it's like a burn.
I think that he started thinking,
he started saying stuff like,
this isn't a prank because it,
but I think you'd always go back to the fact that there was paperwork.
It was real and that was probably the biggest mistake is it's some,
somebody at an administration was,
do you guys that video,
that's a work
of art.
Burleson Brendan as a prankster has to just accept his defeat.
Well,
and Duncan trussell's emailed me about giving his my info to you guys for the
podcast and I responded to the email.
Tell Brendan,
nice try.
Never said,
never said give him my contact info.
And then when you guys called me yesterday,
I had that debt he's definitely involved with,
I was going to show up and they're just going to get out of the video camera and
just say,
yeah,
he just drove an hour and nothing.
That's hilarious.
Enjoy.
Enjoy Russia.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
You're out.
Come out to the mound committee bill.
What he said when he did an a in another podcast when he talked about pranking
people,
he said that he only pranks people that he loves and that and that came from the
same thing from us.
But with him,
you know,
he's such a good friend.
We know that we could do that,
but I'm also saying that so that if he listens to this,
we'd love you Brandon.
You'd have to know that you can't get me back to bad.
You gotta to be more.
Now you've got a tweet pictures at least of Brendan that you have on your phone
list.
Notice Brendan,
you are exposed any of it.
You can't have only your victories available for the public to see like the
photos of your whole foods sign.
You have to have your losses.
Yeah.
This is the game he plays and he took a loss.
And you're supposed to put that video online.
Yes.
I think it's,
I think we have that video waiting.
You know that video is just there in case he decides to get me back.
Oh,
it's so crazy.
He should be requesting that he should be required.
He's never asked about it.
He's never asked about the videos and that's the thing I admire about the guy.
He,
he uh,
he plays straight and he keeps his head,
neck,
dad's video online.
You God.
Otherwise the whole game is a sham.
You got to edit it and give it to Conan and then so you can put it on.
That's not a bad idea.
It's funny we'll be on we,
yeah,
we'd actually,
nobody gets hurt.
We get that second day,
right?
Yeah.
If he was smart and he was thinking of suing,
that's,
that would be the motivation presented as a sketch.
To me,
that's not a bad idea to put it back on the show.
That's from the show.
Cause then it pays the whole thing.
I would really give me kind of funny call in and could work with,
you know,
I don't want to do this,
but my lawyers are making me,
you know,
like it can actually be funny.
That's a funny I did for a sketch.
Why don't you do that man?
Make them,
I should edit it with,
with tech.
I wouldn't do it.
I want to do it without permission.
I even feel bad about talking about without permission because it,
oh my God,
listen,
if he doesn't give you permission,
then what is he?
No,
he wouldn't not give permission,
but as a respectable,
listen,
Brendan Walsh is a bad motherfucker.
Ultimately he's going to have to accept that he got them and then it's
hilarious.
It's going to come back so much.
It's going to come back so much deeper and so trust me,
it's going to come back so hard.
Yeah.
I don't even trust.
I think Rory Scovel after it happened,
he goes,
I might just show up and my fiance will be gone.
I don't know why.
Right.
He's capable of,
I don't know.
Can you call a truce?
Do you think it will accept a truce?
Um,
are you even
now when you feel like you even does that SNL?
That's pretty rude.
That would be more because I did another thing to him once where he was,
I knew that these people were having a,
a lemonade stand and he was at it.
He's other comedians and silver lake and I went as meeting with somebody,
like a meeting,
a writing meeting,
and I picked him up and just said,
hey,
get in the car,
we're going to buy water balloons and we're just going to water balloon the shit
out of this mum and aid stand.
And so we,
we had,
we pulled up and had three guys in the back and everything and this guy puts his
head out the window goes,
hey,
how much does the lemonade,
and they got 25 cents of before they finished.
Just started railing them with,
with water balloons in painful and to the point where it was like,
all right,
I've definitely made myself vulnerable to getting multiple bad things done to me
for my friends.
Yeah.
That sets it up.
That starts it up.
Yeah.
Especially when they're in their clothes and they like talking to,
they were holding their iPhone while we are adults.
We have adult things with us and water ballooning isn't always part of that.
So how many times do you guys got him back and forth?
Just a couple.
Do you think it's possible to call a truce?
Who's he?
Who's at right now?
Yeah,
I wouldn't mind.
Maybe we call him up right now and call it truth.
Do you feel like,
and wish we had the capability,
we've never set up the capability to take phone calls.
Speakerphone.
Well we know Mike,
you can do that.
You get your phone.
Yeah,
call him up.
I love,
we love Brendan,
but I just text Brendan I guess has to be on this has to be on the Internet.
I text him.
Ken,
Nick Thune play your beard prank.
Holly Harry Potter video on Conan.
Conan.
Sorry.
Well don't even say Ancona Cause who knows if Colin wants to have anything to do
with it.
Well I want you to tweet team Coco does team coco answers tweets.
Yeah,
they're really,
do I have to,
can I just put them on speaker right away or not to ask his permission?
Uh,
yeah,
he just tell desk squatter.
Tell him right away.
Yeah,
he's got a lot on our podcast is on Brian's a podcast network that's called the
bone zone.
Ryan,
Anna,
Anna.
See the fact that he hasn't even told you that story.
It shows you,
when did this happen?
Four or five months ago.
Oh,
how dare he.
Four or five months.
He has,
no,
he doesn't.
Oh my God.
He just wrote back.
Fuck you.
Seriously.
Oh really?
Oh,
Brian's fines.
Goofin
terrified.
Oh my God.
Shows his power.
He's a serious man.
That,
thank you for calling me.
Leave me a message.
That's a really nice voice mail message as it's solid.
Good voicing.
He's probably watching this live.
Haha.
Oh,
for delivery option.
What's the delivery options anyways?
You could say hey,
it's meaning soon.
Um,
I just wanted to see if we,
I'm on the podcast right now on the Joe Rogan experience and um,
just wanted to see if we can get an on air prank.
Yeah.
We want to call it truce ban.
That was Joe.
Guys don't need to be going after each other like this.
Concentrate in new careers.
It's a person.
It's the first online prank trees ever happened.
Live in a pod.
Concentrated your relationships.
Get it together or not,
or not.
Or keep it going,
but let us use the video ease.
I actually at work right now here.
I wrote back what Conan question mark.
So yeah,
to it happening?
You don't think so.
So you have the video?
We do.
Multiple people have it.
We had,
it was like a six camera shoot.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Awesome.
That's whole areas with lots of it.
How long did it take for you guys to plan this in the dressing room alone?
We had iPhones just set up around the room filming,
so it was all like randomly like they were placed and we were also like taking
pictures.
He was posing.
He was,
he was glad handing and does so he was glad him.
Oh my God,
Jesus Christ.
How long did it take for you guys to plan this out?
Just five less than five minutes.
Then it was really happening as it went.
Oh,
so you did a little bit of ad libbing.
Yeah,
it was.
A lot of it was,
oh,
so the Walter thing,
Lori and John Doerr was so involved and they were seriously going on Conan.
I mean there was up to them about to go on stage when I was like,
Hey,
I'm,
I feel really bad about what we did.
And they're like,
and JP.
He's like,
why don't we let them focus on their performance at this point and a tough stop
pranking people.
Jesus Christ.
That's the problem with comedians.
Even with a really important job like working for Conan.
Ultimately if you're a comedian,
you're kind of a bit of a fuck up.
My Dad was a prank or when when I was younger he would like put,
we would go on family vacation and my uncle Rod would come and my dad would
stick.
I'm dirty diapers like the day that everybody was leaving and my younger
brothers are dog shit from my,
our dog and it was a suitcase
and then he would get home.
My mom would get my mom's brother,
I don't even know if he called that pranking.
That's just rude.
Well it is ranking.
You know,
it's kind of a poetic Brendan,
just text.
I'm working.
Yeah.
It is a prank.
People.
It's sort of a prank.
People get on Brendan Walsh given on them on Twitter,
get on him
in his video.
He's a great guy.
I'm just scared of him.
You scared of retribution?
I'm pretty sure if it was played on and that he would totally say yes.
I'm pretty.
Unless there's something weird at Man pod Harry Potter thing that he doesn't
like,
but that's hilarious.
Wouldn't you saying if it's on Kona,
but it doesn't need to be on Conan,
just tell him the internet.
No,
no.
I'm gonna say,
but that would be awesome for him.
And that's something that I think Conan would totally do.
I think even just have it on the Internet and it would get,
let's get Conan on the phone.
Texting my dad helps him.
He had like a pant when he was young.
He had like a pant,
they ripped pants.
People just pull it bad.
So yeah,
it's the oldest trick in the book,
but it's most of the time,
the most funny thing you could ever do to anybody.
Yeah.
Especially as guys get older to develop guts.
Their parents are barely hanging on anyway.
My Dad and he saw,
they're handsome.
My Dad and godfather would,
we'd have,
they would pass each other and in awkward situations and it was just kind of
like,
who knows when it's going to do next?
And I have twin brothers,
so one of them is like my dad holding my twin brothers in a grocery store and
him just coming up from behind and he's checking out silly.
Wow.
He,
Brendan Walsh,
I was totally wrong.
He wrote back,
I'm at rehearsal.
Fuck that shit.
Zody said,
oh,
okay.
He said,
I'm at rehearsal.
Fuck that shit.
He's mad at you,
dude.
I know.
That's why I said in the beginning I did not want to do it,
but wow.
You know what I,
every time I'm sitting out to do a podcast on the way there,
I say to myself something that good that you wouldn't share.
I would say to myself on the way to every podcast,
remember,
you don't have to say everything of your life.
There's some things,
because I've already got,
I got in trouble on another podcast podcast on,
um,
comedy,
Bang,
Bang.
What'd you do?
Talk about my neighbor.
How'd you get in trouble?
Because my neighbor heard it.
I play the audio,
I played audio of him in his pack.
I'm the worst person you played on you.
What was he doing?
It's,
I can't even,
I ha,
it's to the point where I can't,
I should,
I probably shouldn't have brought it up.
Well,
you [inaudible] get in trouble.
It's like,
give us a king was I was out of line and it was funny and it was like a funny
bit and he liked it.
And then,
um,
his wife didn't like it that much because he played it for her after he heard it
and I was stupid and I said his name and everything.
Oh Dude,
boom,
boom.
She,
I did some,
I did something bad.
They went back and cut it out of the podcast.
So we were really nice about it.
I remember when I was talking about the girl at the tanning salon a long time
ago,
I think her,
one of her friends must have listened to the podcast or something or,
or said something to her because now she came like a month ago or two months
ago.
I don't think I've ever said this.
What was the girl at the Tanning Salon?
What was the story again?
She was super high and that every time I'd go there and Tan I would just
fucking,
you know,
I'll try to masturbate to her while I'm getting a Tan.
I mean she just fucking high.
Yeah.
Well she said something to me,
she's like,
hey,
keep your hands away from your parts or something stupid.
Like she said something like that wouldn't I was,
she's like,
alright,
number room number 11 keep your hands away from your parts.
Oh,
rule number 11 or room number 11 oh yeah,
room number.
And she just kind of threw that in at the end and I just walk and go,
what the heck?
What was the first 10 rules?
Yeah,
it was like this.
I got confused.
Yeah,
that's hilarious.
So basically she's saying she wants some deck one.
Now I,
there's this little latch,
there's just like a little fishing hook.
I just keep that undone now.
Like on the door,
like when you shut the door there's that little latch where it's like a little
hook that goes into the hole in a door lock.
I just keep that unlocked and just shut the door.
And just in case,
oh this listen to what happened to me last week.
I was,
I don't even know what the fuck you just said just in case for what if she is
interested in getting some Dick while I'm tanning.
I'm keeping that door and lock.
So you still go to the same place?
Of course.
I didn't even know you tan.
How often need tam?
Once every month.
Two months.
Really?
It's relaxing.
Plus it's,
I don't know.
I don't,
I think it's a new nap when you tend to get vitamin D out of those tanning
salons.
Like you do other son.
Yeah and I like she in California cause you could just go outside and lay out.
Right.
We know that that's like been shown to improve endurance that when you get
tanned like a lot of fighters tan right before they fight cause it actually
improves your endurance and that crazy and they look better.
Yeah.
What actually it might,
it might have a bunch of other effects too with the B six that your body
produces when you're,
uh,
when you're tanning.
Apparently it's a,
it's like amazing for your health nuts cause we've always been told to stay out
of the sun because he get cancer,
right?
Yeah.
Then Seattle,
cause where I'm from,
they promote tanning as in like you need to get because you have a 40 days
without sign up there.
Yeah.
Oh,
so the decoding just for health.
That's what,
yeah,
I mean that's probably,
that's part of what they're saying and that,
you know,
like the tanning salon,
I asked her,
we went back to sleep with that dirty girl.
It seems like a disinfectant,
you know,
like you're just getting blasted by
so it will kill any kind of fucking nasty little light bulbs are going to kill
the fucking funk.
They can live in.
Some chicks gave her that I've ever done.
My wife,
my wife used to work at one.
He's pretending these getting zapped this for a moment.
This is a grown man grown man lying after his fuck.
Some dirty girls.
He's lying there with goggles on.
Go a little kill it or kill it all cooks to cook
bare ass.
I keep the underwear on but I should go bare ass cause then it would give me
like,
you probably got a nice table.
You get it from,
maybe your Dick would get less sensitive and leathery.
You dig a bit like an old lady that's pentanance and shit.
Do you get to as a young girl,
do you get the spots in your back?
Some people like I've noticed when they tan they get like their shoulder blades
create spot.
Yeah.
No,
not weird.
I love that show.
Their boobs and your butt cheeks.
You Butt cheeks create them too.
I don't get that.
When you said the sun doesn't go.
I like to put the little stickers of the hearts and the really cheesy things on
me when I,
when I tagged so that if,
uh,
you know,
I have my shirt off.
It looks really,
really,
really homo
and the only people that see that girls,
so it's really stupid for me to do was wrong thing.
Anytime you're fucking with your nipples,
just anything.
What are you doing?
Any guy and doing things with their nipples.
That's why when you see a guy with like nipple rings,
you're like,
oh,
okay,
what else is going on?
What else is going well here?
Man?
Right belly button.
Is it,
is it because of stuff like that feels good for them?
I don't know.
It seems erotic or drawing attention.
There's the,
it's,
yeah,
it's like they're making a statement.
There may,
it's more that than anything.
I suppose.
Even if you were looking for a super sexual person,
when you're,
you've got nick rings through your Nipples,
you know,
you're kind of letting everybody know you're a freak,
right?
Not there's anything wrong with it.
A lot of athletes do it.
I've seen a lot of athletes that have nipple rings.
I don't know why.
You know,
a few fighters of nipple rings.
I don't know why it's,
it's part of their uniform at what's it's like sets them apart when they're on
TV.
Especially the fighters because there shirtless,
right?
Well,
yeah,
but they don't fight with nipple rings on and they're pussies.
Really.
I'm just kidding.
Please.
You fight the warriors of old,
how much piercing do you think they did back in the day?
There's just say pirates had earrings,
right?
Right.
Pearson has been going on forever.
But has it been going on over the body like people do now?
Like with Nipples and share thing?
Probably like there's African ears.
Those boys were like,
oh yeah,
really nasty shit.
Craziest thing is the fucking the mouth thing.
They do the,
the,
I think it's Siri is a part of Africa.
I think that's where it is.
Where they,
uh,
they stretched their lips out,
they stick a fucking odd,
uh,
sharp sticks with their fucking lower lip and they slowly start to stretch it
out.
It goes further and the more they stretch it out,
the bigger the plate they can fit in their lip.
The more cattle they're worth.
When would they get married off and that crazy.
What about this next stretch of bitches?
Oh that's not so if they take those off their debt.
Yeah.
Because they can't support their neck.
They're not only that,
their neck is like way longer than it's supposed to be,
but it's the perfect blow job.
You basically have no neck muscle anymore.
That's what that create.
Cause they,
I don't know what,
who the fuck's idea was that
they didn't want the guys to come back down.
You guys,
African women with the plates in their lip,
they have to bang out their lower teeth.
Yeah.
At one point.
They've,
yeah,
they've got to bang out their lower teeth and it just,
it just dangles.
Yeah.
Well,
when you take the plate out,
it's disgusting.
Have you heard about this new mouthwash,
speaking of teeth that,
uh,
that they're testing at Ucla?
It's like a,
uh,
a bomb.
Like you just do it once every four days and it just,
no cavities.
So dead and Amir from that shit.
It's going to kill you too,
man.
It's going to kill everything.
I guess the whole thing is it kills the one virus that causes tooth decay and
release.
It just knocks it out so like you know that dentists are going to take over that
and so you won't be able to buy it in the stores.
You're going to tell you we're going to see not to brush for four days.
You're going to find that you have to do anything except for Tartar.
You know what?
You're going to take it and you're going to feel like an ass to poison in your
body.
It's a poison.
If it worked.
Yeah,
but can it really can it really can.
It really just they can target.
Just brush your teeth.
You Nasty Lady.
She said,
I started using arm and hammer and it actually makes my teeth whiter.
I haven't had like white teeth forever.
Really?
Armand Hammer works.
What is like baking soda?
Yeah,
the baking soda stuff.
That works great.
I used to brush my teeth with begging,
so Nikki Glaser told me too.
It's crest plus.
My parents were hippies,
so we used to use baking soda
as toothpaste and I was a kid.
I don't want to get actual baking soda and it must work.
Yeah,
it does work.
I,
it's something happened to me last week.
You were mentioning the latches on the room on the door.
I had a bathroom latch experience of somebody.
Oh No.
But I did it.
I did a standup show last week at this Alexandria Hotel,
which is downtown.
It's just you like,
it's now like a halfway house,
but it used to be in the 20s like the best place.
And I got there early and had to take a shit.
So I'd go to the guy that books is shell.
This guy named Josh,
no one really there yet.
I found the guy's bathroom and there's only four standing urinals next to it.
There was another room with no lock on the door that was just no toilet seat.
So you just had to sit on the like a,
it's a shy and so I went down to the bar and there was no lock on that bathroom
door.
So you can be in their shitting and somebody just walk in.
So then the,
the toilets on the other side of the room.
So there's no like holding the door even.
It's just
like somebody walks in and,
sorry,
just sitting in the corner.
So I went up to the guy that
books to trial.
I said,
where do I,
and he goes,
oh,
you know what,
there's this girl's bathroom on this floor nobody knows,
really knows about and nobody uses.
And so he goes bit in,
it's totally empty right now and be fine.
So I go over there and sure enough,
the bathrooms empty,
there's two stalls.
So I go on this one and then as I'm finished,
this girl comes in and sits in the stall next to me and I moved my feet over and
she just starts farting and shitting.
Her brain's just like,
plop.
And I'm just sitting there like,
oh my,
you know,
trying to be as quiet as possible.
My,
I'm like beating up.
Um,
and as she's almost finished,
this other girl walks in and tries to go and now these doors fold in so they,
it folds in the middle and the latches don't match up.
So like over time they don't,
they don't,
so the door comes in,
knows he can block it,
but it like caves in.
So she tries to go in,
the girl's stall next to me first and the girls like,
um,
styles taken.
But the stall next to me isn't,
ah,
and the girl
and she starts,
I'm thinking I can get away with not making a noise,
just do it,
girl.
I'm holding the door.
I was going to do girl voice as holding the doors.
She keeps pushing like,
you know,
like just stop pushing if you feel resistance.
She keeps pushing the advance.
He goes,
there's someone in there and I just go,
yeah,
I'm in here.
Oh,
wrapped up out of the bathroom.
The girl next to me wipes up leaves.
And I'm sitting there like,
oh gosh,
dude,
there's only one way out.
There's only one way I know that they're going to see me.
So I wait a couple minutes,
it's and funny,
like get up and start to walk out and there's turn up girl across the room.
I see her watching me walk out and I want just walk up to her and uh,
and she goes,
you just heard me take a shit?
And I said,
yeah,
that was you.
I,
um,
that was,
I'm so sorry about that.
As I'm talking to her,
the guy that books the show that told me to go in there and walks up and he
goes,
hey,
have you met my girlfriend?
And Ah,
and I probably know
her better than he does is a sad thing.
But I like to think that maybe in some other world that after he told me to go
to that bathroom,
he ran up to her and he's like,
Hey,
now's your chance.
Get in there and take a shit.
Did you imagine if they were freaks who that's what they were into their went to
having other men listening could have been shit.
Ben,
do you think so?
Is it possible?
What's the Po?
What is the potential?
Well,
you know,
20% standup lies you people come up to you on the road that are freaks.
It usually happens at least once a weekend for me.
Like I met them at a comedy club were swingers.
Yeah.
We get that.
Well comes in.
Well,
they just hang out for a while and it's the point to where the show is over and
you're just hanging out with the people,
your friends or whoever.
You had the swingers happen a lot.
Yeah,
I've had that.
I think it was Tampa.
I think there's a big swinger.
Yeah,
that sounds,
yeah,
it sounds like it.
Yeah.
We did a show and then afterwards it's fucking,
people were telling us there,
there were disgusting.
They would tell us their swingers.
They could just come on down and you can just watch,
wait,
whoa,
whoa.
Are you inviting me to watch you go?
Fuck.
Like really?
Like I was going to go back to the hotel and watched some paper view.
Maybe is a good mood.
That's a real person.
Check my email once you can watch us.
Fuck.
You know,
why don't we just facetime it?
What you're entering into a world of uncertainty,
you know,
I mean,
you could tell they were all cool.
We're all friends.
It's very unsettling and it's,
it's also weird when you look at them and you know that they're like,
you're,
you're not leading your life quite right.
Yeah.
Something's going on.
Something's not good with you guys.
We were in,
uh,
I forget what city it was.
I shouldn't say anyway,
even if I knew,
uh,
but me and Ari had this guy that was driving us around.
It was a very conservative city,
I'll tell you that.
I won't say the city,
but anyway,
this guy was driving us around and he was a real nice guy and,
uh,
seemed like real proper,
you know,
kind of a southern dude.
And then on the last day,
he's driving us to the airport and he starts mentioning swinger clubs,
the law out of nowhere.
He just got comfortable with us like the rest,
the rest of the weekend he was,
yes sir.
Mr Rogan,
what'd you,
you know,
what time is the show?
Mr Rogan.
Okay.
We'll meet you downstairs at seven 30.
Sharp.
And he was super friendly and,
oh,
by the way,
if you'd like to have sex with multiple people,
yeah.
Or my wife let me know,
or my wife.
So,
um,
me and Ari get to the airport and he starts telling us,
you know,
if you ever want to come by and you know,
and uh,
check it out,
you just let me know and you know,
come by and check it out.
Like,
what do you guys do?
You know?
He goes,
well,
we're swingers.
I go,
you're swingers.
He goes,
yeah.
And I go,
wow.
So you let your,
your wife fucks other dude.
He goes,
well,
I get to say,
uh,
you know,
if I don't like it,
I get to say no.
If I don't like it,
you get to say no.
Obviously.
Like I was like,
what do you,
when do you get to say no?
And he brought up some story about,
the wife was looking at this big one.
This guy is a,
he's a big guy
and he was just too big and you know,
I know he's a black guy.
And he goes,
no,
we don't do that.
We don't do that.
I go,
so you don't have black guys fucker.
And he goes,
no,
no.
I would say no.
He goes,
I just don't,
I don't want to have to measure up,
if you know what I mean.
And he ends this weird attitude about it.
It was very strange.
You know,
he just left.
He was in his fifties he was not a young guy.
Yeah,
he was gray hair get to get to a place of,
you're just trying things out.
Yeah,
I guess so maybe.
Or maybe he's just fucked up and I,
he seemed like a normal guy.
The real problem is you go to,
to really get to know someone,
you have to have some conversations with them.
It takes some time.
It's one of the cool things about doing a podcast.
It's for two hours.
Yeah.
You get to talk,
you,
you get to know someone.
It hits when you're just talking to a guy like,
hey,
we'd like to go get something to eat.
Where's the steakhouse getting drivers there?
You don't get to know them that well.
Yeah.
Ask him a few questions.
Grow up here yesterday.
I grew up in Buffalo.
You don't,
you don't really know him that well.
I know some people that just tell drivers like,
hey man,
I just don't want to talk.
Really.
People do that.
Wow.
I think that's rude.
It's so rude.
I,
um,
I always make them my friend.
I'd take them to the shows.
I take them to the UFC.
I like it.
I get them tickets.
I get them on,
not all of them.
Now we're going to drive her last week.
Yeah.
Well,
every now and then there's some of them are not nice or,
or not into it.
They just don't want,
you know,
it's not an older guy.
He doesn't want to hang out with some fucking young idiots,
you know.
But the last few guys,
we get them to the UFC,
we get them to the comedy clubs and hanging out.
We'll go to dinner with them by their dinner.
It's,
we'd make them like,
so that they're just there,
the guy who was driving,
but they get to have as much fun as we're having,
you know?
So it's,
it's for them.
It's a great weekend.
You know,
anytime I am tip the shit out of him.
Yeah.
When,
when they get to hang out too with like a celebrity,
you know,
that that makes him excited sometimes.
I mean maybe they're the board of it,
but I just want to make sure that while they're working it doesn't seem like
work.
And I'm like,
you look the only,
you know,
just hang out with us man.
We'll have some fun.
And some of them have been great.
You know the,
you know,
the people that comedy clubs that pick you up or take you,
sometimes they've got like a separate person.
The person that drives you to rate it on
those,
there's so many of those in my mind and sometimes I'll find me on Facebook and
write to me and it's like,
well I don't,
what city was this cat?
Yeah,
but half the time you have you ever think,
how do we know they're a good driver?
There was one,
I remember,
man,
where the guy was a,
it was in Florida and the guy was talking all this shit about all the other
comedians that come there.
Oh yeah,
that's happened.
Why did they do that?
So many guys do that.
This guy,
wow,
we thinks he can sell tickets.
Couldn't even sell out.
Then tell how one champ gossipy,
and then this guy,
you know,
you don't want,
I think what his problem is,
he thinks she's a funnier comic than it really is.
And a lot of these guys,
they don't want to do radio.
I got him up,
I get him up at six o'clock and he's like,
going through this.
I'm like,
dude,
what are you going to say about me?
Yeah,
this is gross.
I have one college that books a lot of people that I know and
I had a terrible thing happen there and it's every time told to every comedian.
And so it was,
it was in a theater,
it was in a theater.
And the,
uh,
this one I'm not actually sad,
scared about,
but the a is a packed theater and there's a one seat open in the front row and
this kid walks in and if this is 10 minutes into the show and it's a good show
so far,
this kid walks in wearing a maroon shirt with a silver tie wrap around Oakleys
and black pants.
He looks like he works at like hate or something and he's holding a six foot
both staff and fingerless gloves with the,
with the Oakleys,
he walks right up to the front row,
walks right down the middle and sits down in the seat like nothing's out of
place with a big staff,
a both staff,
a six foot both staff.
And I know that because I later was asking what like a crossbow that you like
took on being a thing happen.
Yeah.
Okay.
So the fuck,
I look at the guy and I go,
are you from the future?
Like,
I didn't know what I started getting good response out of it and then I couldn't
let it go that he was wearing sunglasses because in my mind,
he was a frat kid that was trying to be funny for everyone in that room and I
was not going to let him be went on me.
And so eventually I got started getting more angry about it and it was like,
take your sunglasses off.
Like just,
I know you've already disrupted the show.
You walked down,
just take off your,
and you just wouldn't,
he wouldn't,
he was such a smart ass.
I thought,
oh no.
So I did.
He did talk a little bit now he wasn't blind.
Like I found those things out.
Um,
so at one point it got so bad that I couldn't stop talking about people were
walking out and this girl in the front row,
at one point I was just like sitting on the stool just like angry.
And she goes,
can you just start telling jokes again?
Oh.
And I looked at it and I said,
you're right.
I won't bring it up again.
I'm sorry.
It's very,
very unprofessional.
Finished the show out without mentioning it.
And I did.
Walked offstage,
was angry about it and I just kept saying like,
who does that?
Who walks in front row?
You know,
she,
this lady comes back and she goes,
oh that boy is a boy around campus that everybody knows.
He dresses like that every day.
There's also a boy here that dress like a pirate and they're special.
And I was like,
oh,
okay.
So from now on if a comedian comes or any a band or anybody that doesn't go
here,
that might be talking to a group of people to say,
Hey,
at some point a guy with sunglasses and a bow staff is going to walk in.
Just ignore him.
He's special.
Just say that to people from now on.
So that way they,
cause every comedian will comment on that.
I mean,
how do you not comment on a pirate guy or a bow staff guy?
Was he saying anything to you?
Was he heckling or he wasn't giving me response is just kind of snobby.
He didn't seem like he was that.
I just seem like he's just a special kid.
Like he just is a bit off.
Right.
So you thought they just being cocky?
Yeah,
I thought it was like a kid that was just trying to fuck with me.
Oh Wow.
I totally misread it and let it get to my pride,
you know?
But every comedian people all the time or just like,
Hey,
I played this place.
And they said,
uh,
he told us the whole story and they said don't do that.
Wow.
Yeah.
So you're the example.
Yeah,
it was a college.
It's not like I was going to go back.
Do you like doing colleges?
They're fun sometimes.
I just,
I do.
Um,
I've been doing this comedy Central College tour this summer.
Well,
headline,
like a couple of college shows every couple of weeks.
And do you find it like it's almost like you have to explain things more or I
don't change a thing and I'm not saying that in like a way of saying that.
I'm curious.
I don't yet,
but I just go up and do like I would at a comedy club and some things they get,
some things they don't get the,
the things that they don't get.
There's a couple of kids that get it and they like it even more,
you know?
But you know,
I have jokes fall flat here and there.
It's,
you never know which one and where,
you know,
their life experience is so limited.
Sometimes you tell a joke,
you're like,
oh yeah,
that's because you don't,
yeah,
I remember I was in the University of Miami and I was talking about something
sexual and then I paused and I said,
are any of you guys virgins?
And a bunch of people put their hands up like way more than I would've expected.
Was it,
was it a religious school?
No,
I don't think so.
It was just a regular college.
It was like,
wow.
So there's,
you know,
18 year olds are say they didn't know what I was talking about.
They were just baffled.
They look shocked.
Literally I was assaulting them with information that they didn't really need.
Well,
you're also,
you're also playing some sort of a corporate party because it's a,
it's almost like you were playing for a whole company.
People that see each other every day,
they're not going to laugh at some things in front of those people.
They don't like,
uh,
they don't want the person that they sit next to you to know that they like anal
sex jokes.
Yeah.
Colleges are so strange when you really think about it.
So there is there a little prude bunch of people have paid money to send their
kids to school and I'm certain percentage of that goes to entertainment and they
pay exorbitant amounts of money.
Great money.
Yeah.
For,
well I'll show you can get paid.
So you get paid great.
Great money.
I don't,
I haven't done them.
I haven't done them in a long time because at some point people are making like,
I mean a hundred grand just for a show.
Yeah.
I don't know if that's going on anymore with the economy the way it is.
I don't know why it wouldn't,
oh,
trust.
Still the same amount of people are going to school right there and there's
still that much budget.
I don't know if you want me to tell you what Brendan was.
Yes.
No I don't.
I don't.
And now he's actually just getting interested in my head.
What did he say?
What does the mass head games,
it's pretty sad.
They should pay me for that.
Anyway,
I filled out paperwork.
Now you've got to think that he's not listening to this podcast right now,
so he's probably like this part.
You know the paperwork and everything and he goes,
good prank though.
We'll give you $1,500 a shave your beard.
Psych
1500 bucks.
Yeah,
bucks.
you can get the score.
Didn't take money.
He went and take money.
Yes,
he would know.
I know because I tried giving him,
I tried.
I felt so guilty afterwards.
You tried giving them 1500 bucks?
No,
I tried giving him 400 or 200 if you've got them a check from NBC for 1500 bucks
or whatever TVs for 1500 bucks.
I just turned down money the other day.
Joe And I turned down,
I think you'd agree with,
I think Britain washes when it told me not to do it.
Uh,
I was going to do an abduction video with Veronica and uh,
they were gonna pay us money to be like a boyfriend and girlfriend and then they
were going to duct us and tie us up and they weren't,
it was only me and her in the whole entire video and it was just us like
struggling and in like,
uh,
like they would like focus on my girls but you know,
while she's tied up or something and no nudity for me,
but they were going to pay me $400 to do,
they were going to pay you and make you feel like,
I think it would be,
I know they see,
I don't like being tied up and I hope first of all is this a porn company that
was doing this fetish company is that they don't get,
they don't do porn but it's like they were going to kill you.
Now you're about to be a snob samples and it would be like this guy and the girl
tied up in the backseat of a car and they're just like,
oh,
help me get out of here man.
Hell,
I can't get up beat off to them.
And then is that when no,
nothing.
It's just me being tied up and trying to get free and they just be naked with
clothes on and I thought I could make it our funnel.
I like,
it would be funny if you are watching those ones,
which is a great democratic fuck your girl while you're tied up to,
that's what the real deal and then we're going to go look,
she's a porn star.
You signed up for this.
That's what you signed up for.
It's so weird.
There's people like that shit though.
People were getting tied up.
Yeah.
If someone started screaming,
no,
you would just have to accept the fact you're in this porn.
What's like the like the clothes,
the clothes lines like pinching the skin around the rope.
Have you seen that?
Really?
People like that are just tied up by a ton of rope.
Not just like hands tied,
like their body is like,
oh right,
yeah,
I've seen this really,
really intensely tied and there's like clothing pins around them.
It's very scary looking at what the fuck man,
how did you get there?
And then they have these rope marks that are just ridiculous and how much are
they going to pay you to tell you about $400
she was getting honored.
I don't get as much as her as your Adrian,
I'm going to have to ask for more money.
So how long,
how long had you been together?
They have a lot of internet credibility,
Bro.
Don't sell yourself for 400 bucks.
Somebody video comes out,
you know,
red band and his girlfriend get tied up.
Do you know when people want to tie you up and fucked here was my excuse because
the shoot,
because she can't take a job Ryan.
It comes like,
no you should.
It's,
he can make it a she said you'd be doing it.
No,
no.
She was like,
she didn't tell me but she's like,
you could make it like a joke.
It could be funny.
So your fans and everybody will think it's funny.
And I'm like,
yeah,
but you know what self,
I'm sure I would do a better job and I would make it even better.
You know,
like,
yeah,
I can make my own fitness.
It's going to be a guy there to just,
no,
it's just me and you probably know better people is the camera man isn't talking
shit to you.
No,
no,
no.
It's just like,
he goes,
all right,
now you're going to be in the car struggling to get her in the car struggling.
And then all of a sudden I got to go get the fuck down.
W W we're just filming something.
Shut the fuck up.
The guy puts a gun in your face and you don't even realize that that's the real
script.
The real script is that they want to do.
Uh,
and then he just raped.
Wait,
a porno sits there waiting.
Want to see what a fetishes like mother fuckers crazy fuck you.
And I think some church,
it's like a Dexter here.
What happens is they get you tied up and then they just robbed you.
And they were like,
you idiot,
we were going to pay you 400 bucks.
Yeah.
Anybody who's willing to lock your now doing that for 400 bucks isn't going to
have a lot of money on them.
I think that'd be worth.
Robbins was a legit company,
but then they use a legit,
they have like a full website and they sent me all the samples and everything.
We're about to be in a snuff film,
some of the cloud.
We've set it up,
they look,
we can get them,
we can get it for 400 bucks and then we're going to,
if we really want to get them to spending a lot of money,
let's,
let's offer him $1,000.
Now he's going to know it's bullshit.
Why would we give him $1,000?
His girlfriend is in the business.
Listen,
the kid will do it for 400 bucks,
400 bucks,
and then we kill him.
They said I could wear a mask if I wanted it to.
One of those,
um,
those uh,
Guy Fawkes mask.
Oh Gosh,
I would probably want to wear a bank robber ski masks.
Things with the eyes cut out.
I think that would look pretty cool.
It'd be like,
Hey,
I'm a halflife guy tied up masks.
Oh,
that would even be better.
That's what I was saying.
That's the guy fall.
I think that's his name guy fault,
isn't it?
Then that's it.
He imagined being the guy that designed that mask and be like,
Hey,
I thought it was just for this movie and what the,
I think it's about that guy.
It's no,
the real mask is a about the original design I believe is that guy that tried to
blow up something in England.
They have guy Fawkes day.
Oh from Ocean's 11 well no,
he's from real life.
Another French guy for oceans death squad though.
I have that mask in my window.
Got As long.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's the mass.
That guy,
the guy looked like that.
That was like,
what is a,
this is what it looked like.
So that's from the movie though?
Yeah,
it is.
But it's based on this guy bro.
It's based on this guy whose actual design of that mask.
I'm saying that the guy that designed that math for the movie,
he probably thought,
you know,
he's just a,
well,
the reason why anonymous takes it,
and the reason why I was in that movie vi is that this mask of this guy,
this guy stood for,
I mean,
they,
they celebrate him like they celebrate,
um,
right.
Independence Day over here.
When we were there,
they were blowing off fireworks and shit.
We were in England for Guy Fawkes Day and uh,
they had fireworks going off and they all wear that mask.
No,
but the driver was explaining to me what it was all about and that,
and I go,
so basically he was a terrorist.
The guy tried to,
you know,
blow up whatever they had was a parliament or whatever,
whenever they call it.
Let me see.
When he tried to blow up,
well,
whatever he tried to do,
he,
he planned to assassinate King James.
And um,
he was,
uh,
going there to blow things up when they killed him and they executed them.
But because that this guy,
because he was making that effort,
became this hero and became this representation of we're not going to take your
bullshit.
And so that's why in v they use that,
what does a vendetta fee favor the use that mask.
And that's why that mask has been adopted by the anonymous movement.
It's like the same spirit behind that guys,
what they live by.
Is that one guy still involved in the,
the guy that Lucas or what was his name?
That guy that was the main Lauren who talking about Ellucian.
The Guy,
the main guy from anonymous that was getting you talking about the Wiki leaks.
Love God.
I just crossed wikileaks with anonymous Julian Assan she's talking about,
yeah,
he's um,
I think he's still getting fucked,
man.
I think that guy still has to go to the police and check in every day has got
like some crazy house arrest thing that he's under for sexual misconduct and
another country.
And you know what the charges,
it's like some,
some derivative of rape.
And essentially what happened was this,
he was fucking this check.
They were sleeping together.
And,
uh,
while they were sleeping,
he stuck in inside of her,
you know,
and he didn't have a condom on.
And that's like,
uh,
some sort of a rape situation.
Like,
first of all,
that's stupid.
Well,
that's,
you know what,
the sleepwalking man?
No,
it was,
it,
he,
you can't rub vaginas and penises together in the middle of the night naked and
not,
and not assume that one's going to go flying in there.
You know,
you have to put fucking panties.
But he did it on purpose though,
right?
I don't know.
Who knows?
You know,
it could be,
yes,
it could be that they paid the check to,
to make a big deal out of this,
to,
to embarrass him into a discredit wikileaks,
because it does to a certain extent when they're interviewing or like,
is there,
are you sure you don't remember anything odd?
Oh,
well,
one night,
you know what man,
what a person does sexually.
I mean,
that doesn't seem like rape to me.
That seems like he's kind of a weaselly dude.
But I kind of figured he was a weasley dude anyway.
You know what I mean?
You ever watch them dance?
There's videos of Julian Assange dancing,
you know,
and he's most certainly like housewives cult cult of personality thing going on.
You know,
he mo mostly looking guy though most certainly enjoys it,
but he's also doing some really brave shit,
you know,
and we expect our heroes to be 100% perfect and that is fucking ridiculous.
They're going to do a movie about it.
I'm sure they will hear that.
They will.
He's so fucking brilliant guy.
I mean what he did was pretty amazing then.
You know,
love it or hate it.
He got some information loose that opened a lot of people's eyes to how things
go on and you know,
that's,
that's a,
that's a powerful thing.
I mean and,
and when,
when it comes to history,
you know,
when it comes to the history of intelligence and you know,
in,
in distributing information through a digital form,
like,
you know,
like being able to burn things on CD and burn information on Usbs,
that shit will never happen again.
Like what?
What?
What happened with this one soldier when he was able to do they,
they're going to make sure that fucking never happens again.
All because of this one.
Got It.
Probably historically,
but historically [inaudible] super important and they still got him fucked on
this one weird sex charge,
man.
When you think about all the fucking things that you,
somehow bankers have done all the fucking things that politicians have done,
this congress thing that they had on 60 minutes where they show the insider
trading that Congress is guilty up.
Congress are exempt from insider trading laws so they can just insider trade all
day long.
They get information,
they sell and buy stock based on it and they don't even go to jail for it.
It's fucking madness.
That's still happening right now.
It's still happening right now.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's depressing as fuck man.
This,
this is why anonymous,
this is Guy Fawkes it's all the same shit.
It's the shame shit has been going on forever and 1570 this Guy Fox existed.
You know,
think about that.
1570s it was the same bullshit,
same bullshit.
The assholes on top trying to keep the man down.
Everybody's crazy and the pissed off.
They want to blow things up.
I mean this is the same thing in 2011 the only difference is now people are just
sleeping in tents in front of building.
Short of,
I think it's,
it's just beginning.
I really do.
I think this is what we have here,
man,
is the system that existed in its corrupt form only because the Internet didn't
exist,
but now that the Internet exists,
I don't think it can exist anymore.
It'll be interested to see what if that girl that if that girl really lost a
baby in Seattle and did you read that story?
Yeah,
she did.
Yeah.
I didn't know if they confirmed with the hospital if that was the reason yet or
not or if they'd had an app that you can actually pinpoint a reason why some of
us carry that.
Maybe they haven't actually confirmed it with the hospital last time I read it.
I don't know if they had,
I mean look at Olin makes sense.
She's horribly traumatic situation.
The shakuhachi horrendous when that story is out on the way out and would be
interested to see what happens.
I've seen people tear gas,
man,
it's brutal.
Pepper sprays,
even worse.
Pepper sprays up burns,
man,
it's horrendous.
I've seen people get hit with it.
If photoshops are so amazing now,
if I were that guy spraying where that people are putting it in like different
pieces like spark,
like,
oh what an asshole.
That guy and you know they got that guy's email address.
They've got that guy's phone number.
They put it all online.
That guy's going to get a lashing from the Internet.
You know?
It's like the only reason why that guy thought that he could do that.
What the fuck would an officer of the police,
why the fuck would an officer or the police think that he could be spraying
pepper spray and the lace is a face full protestors and that that would be a
part of his job.
That was the one from the college right?
From,
yeah,
UC Berkeley or UC Davis,
right?
Was it UC Davis?
What the fuck is that man?
Get what?
What kind of a human being could spray a terrifying thing like pepper gas that
that pepper spray fucking hurts in a little girl's face.
I'm looking at this girl,
she's like 18 years old,
17 years old,
whatever the fuck they are our first year of college and he's blasting them when
they're idealistic face with pepper spray sprayed that are sitting there at a
dance in junior high at my school into the ventilation system and I just had a
little bit of it and,
and had to go out in the air ambulance to the thought of having,
you know,
a full thing sprayed in your face.
Point blank range,
you know,
and this is on top of all the videos of them jabbing kids with batons.
It's like you can't,
no one learns.
We don't learn anything from the 60s were doing the same fucking thing.
But it's just now we have too much information.
The,
the Internet,
this life that you and I are living,
we are the only people ever in the history of humanity that have had the
internet,
the people that like you and I who remember when it didn't exist.
And the people like,
you know,
really young people that were born with it and I've never,
never been without it.
The,
they,
we live in a different era.
This is a different time.
We know vastly more than we ever did when,
you know,
there was no internet when you had to rely on books and magazines and newspapers
and God forbid television news for your information.
Even know if I would have been able to get to your house,
never.
You would have had to get one of those Thomas Guides.
You remember those?
I had one welfare,
uh,
Tom Scott,
he dies.
He uses navigation now.
He gave,
he gave up eventually,
but that mother fucker was Thomas Guide forever.
Yeah.
She's in such a silly goose,
but you know,
this is the only time ever where anybody's had this kind of information in the
system that we have set up right now.
The government system,
our financial system,
all these systems were set up before the Internet.
All these systems were set up.
The system of law,
the,
all this stuff was before everybody could see the transparency of information
that we have today.
Yeah,
I think about when I,
what was your first time you went?
Do you remember the first time you went on the Internet?
Oh,
he's calling us.
Pick up the phone.
Wait.
Oh my speaker phone on speaker phone.
Tell Him
Hey Brendan Walsh.
Hey Brennan.
Do you guys still do on your podcast?
You're on it right now.
Hey Man,
we've got to use that video in the world that the world has.
Got to see you.
What that half a beard.
That Harry Potter outfit.
Yeah,
that's fine.
You're a beautiful man.
Oh,
I know.
It's a hilarious story.
Did I'm glad you want people to see it cause it's hilarious.
Oh sorry about it.
Still.
I guess
he wants to call a truce.
Nick Dude wants to call it to no more pranks.
Are you in the the trousseau no more pranks.
Yeah.
And he gives you $400.
No more prints and he gives you $400.
Yeah.
Uh,
but I don't think that right.
Cause what Nick's retaliation was for wise,
uh,
me tweeting to him.
Congratulations on getting Saturday night live.
We were all,
we're all in seeing the room when I,
me and Chelsea Peretti did it right in front of him.
He was on board with it and then when he got emails,
what would it be?
Funny
he knew he was going to do before he did it.
What I remember was it was more of a,
wouldn't it be funny if we did this?
Oh,
so it wasn't a surprise at all to you?
I didn't know that they were going to think,
wouldn't it be funny if we do this?
The way that it happened,
it didn't feel like,
I didn't think it was actually going to be tweeted,
or at least I didn't think that it was going to happen.
You we did it.
No,
I knew you did.
I knew it.
You told him.
No,
I didn't come as a surprise to me in the sense that I didn't like just get,
start getting messages.
I knew that I've represented the stories.
If it was a huge surprise though,
which is why it was so good to retaliate.
I think that's just the way the story's gone.
Oh,
I see.
So the story morphs over time because it sounds better that way.
Yeah.
I know.
When you're doing a podcast,
when you're doing a podcast,
it sounds better for ticket sales.
It does.
So,
but it makes it,
it makes it,
it makes me feel better about Brendan taught him,
I don't even know this.
You just,
you just,
you just pumped him.
You just told the truth.
But he had already told a lie,
so you pumped him.
That was a lie.
A lie of omission is the same.
You're right.
Well,
you know,
I wouldn't even say it was a lie of omission.
It was a lie of enhancement.
Cause you're a really good storyteller,
you know,
like,
look,
I,
the story is good.
Essentially.
The facts are there.
Yeah.
I'm going to do is I'm going to make it a good story.
I'm going to say that I didn't know Tom.
I'm not talking to a judge here
talking to a podcast.
We love you buddy.
We love you,
man.
Take it easy,
Bro.
Youtube pal by Brandon.
I'm calling you
Brennan Walsh is awesome.
I first saw him open up for Stan hope a a few years back and uh,
loved them ever since.
I've never seen Stan hope lied before.
I love to see him.
Like he's a,
he's in town in Irvine I think on the 30th and a I got to call him up and see if
we can get him on the podcast that week if that's possible.
But I believe it's November 30th.
He's um,
and I will say about the
SNL tweet.
I'm actually half and half on if I fully,
if he tweeted it and then said he tweeted it or if he was,
should I tweet it?
And I think it was like he tweeted,
it said he tweeted it and then Chelsea tweeted it after the fact like,
yeah,
that wasn't that,
that would be funny.
It's okay.
I want to clear it out.
Going to be fine.
November 30th,
Doug,
Stan is going to be at the Irvine Improv
and you better buy your tickets bitches cause it shits going quick.
Guaranteed.
He will sell out.
Doug is only in town for one night and uh,
Doug,
Stan Hope Fan.
If you're,
it's at the Irvine Improv.
If you're a comedy fan and you live anywhere in Orange County or you can make
the drive,
go check them out a Wednesday,
November 30th at eight o'clock because he's awesome.
If you should go with us,
we'll go,
we'll go together.
I'll do it.
You want to go?
Okay.
Wait.
November 30th yeah,
fine.
Actually in this day and in Portland.
Shizam look at you traveler like a chill work in them.
Hippie bitches.
Portland helion.
Come see me.
That's a great club.
Yeah,
I love that.
That's a fun club.
It'd be fun.
Yeah.
I love Portland.
I,
but you're from Seattle,
right?
I did.
You deal with the winter.
How w what does that law yet?
Well,
you don't really realize it when you're living in it for so long until you move
somewhere out.
When you finally live,
like in California during the winter and you,
it freaks you out because you're used to like 40 days,
no sun,
and you're used to people being like trying to dreary and department and then
when the sun comes out,
people freak out.
It's like the best day ever and you get out and you wash your car and you do
everything you can do.
Whereas here,
every day when I first moved down here,
it felt like every day I was just over exerting myself.
Yeah.
We forget about that in California,
that in other parts of the country when it's a nice sunny day,
people go out and do to celebrate.
Like in some clubs,
like the first,
first show tickets suffer if it's a sunny day.
Well for sure.
And if it's in some way,
sometimes if it's a rainy day,
just getting people out.
Yeah,
it's true.
Yeah.
Well that's,
and that's it in like Middle America where people are just like,
ah,
we're just going through this shit.
We don't care.
There's nothing else to do.
Yeah.
We figured it out and it's not bad.
You know?
I love going to,
I love doing stand up all over the place.
I think one of the coolest things about this job is that you really do get to
have like these little bases,
you know,
like you go to these places on a regular basis and you're getting a taste of
everything.
Yeah.
And you also have like this,
you know,
like you draw on a town,
you get used to coming to a town,
you develop fans and it's how you have like a relationship with those people.
I'm just having towns van,
I'm like three or four times back.
It's nice the people come back to see you again.
You know,
like Austin,
Texas is a perfect,
I just did that.
Yeah,
we could go places,
great cap city comedy club and every time we go there it's like we,
I see a lot of the same faces,
you know?
It was a lot of same people afterwards.
You take pictures with so fun fucking time.
They've got a lot of regulars clubs like that.
Yeah.
That's a club.
It's been around forever,
man.
That's,
that's one of the,
this is one of the ones that everybody wants to go to and it's an independent
club.
It's kind of interesting.
What hotel do you stand when you go there?
I ain't tell y'all that Internet fucking crazy.
You don't,
you don't stay where they've put people.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Their places the worst.
Why is it bad?
It's a cop hotel,
so sometimes there's like 30 cop cars in the parking lot at night times.
That's good.
That's a good place to stay.
Just seems scary.
Just don't smoke weed in your room.
Yeah.
Or anywhere within a that's not fun.
You gotta worry about Texas.
Texas is a different animal when it comes to getting arrested for Shit and
Austin,
they're actually really lax about it and their shower
don't give a fuck about it.
You can see into your shower
or from the bed.
There's no wall.
I hate that shit.
Like in Vegas,
when you go to Mandalay band,
you'd walk in and it's like,
oh,
there's the bathroom so you can see anyone,
anyone who went to taking the shower and shit.
Did you see that Obama pardoned?
Uh,
a bunch of people and some of them were drug offenders,
some woman who was um,
shit,
20 years for cocaine.
He commuted her sentence to 10.
He released her after 10 years served and some other,
uh,
marijuana offenses.
He has hard and people fucking just knock all those people out of jails.
It's gotta be a
United States.
Um,
I don't know what the state,
their crimes were committed in,
but you know,
this day and age,
man,
it's really a crime.
The real crime is putting people in jail for it.
It's there.
That's the real crime.
I've heard a lot of on jail for drugs.
People in New York lately,
they've been having a lot of undercover people on the street catching people
smoking joints.
It's been like a big thing.
Of course Bloomberg has a cut.
He's a,
there's an old rich cunt.
All those,
those crazy old men that they don't understand that the system doesn't apply
anymore.
It doesn't work anymore.
It doesn't represent the will of the people and people know it.
And that's why there's a fucking million people in the streets.
It's not temporary.
This is,
this is the beginning of the end and these old guys,
they don't get it.
That's why Giuliana is on TV going,
why don't you occupy a job?
How about your further your education?
Like it's that easy.
Like if you could just go get a job.
What a creepy old asshole old rich man who makes his living giving boring ass
fucking speeches.
I saw one of his speeches when it was post nine 11 speeches.
He was just riding this wave of him being the hero of nine 11.
He,
he took that in the grossest way possible and ran with it politically,
you know,
that he uh,
was strong while that happened.
And you know,
Giuliani represented leadership under duress and every time that's something
that you know,
that people that aren't in struggle latch onto an event,
a tragic event to help them get out of it.
Yeah,
it's horrible.
It's weak.
It's gross.
But what's more gross as you saying something so ignorant as why don't you
occupy a job?
You're telling people that the,
the,
the people that are down there shouldn't be allowed to protest.
They shouldn't be allowed to peacefully demonstrate.
Isn't that like a part of what makes us America is that we can all get together
as a group and say,
hey,
we don't appreciate this.
Yeah.
I've been wondering about the laws on that and how all of a sudden it's just
like cracking down.
I do have to,
the real problem is they realized now that it's not going to go away.
I think they initially let it happen because they thought people were going to
get tired of it and it was going to go away,
but now the momentum behind it is,
it's absurd.
I've never seen anything like this.
The momentum behind it,
it's the point where they have to acknowledge it on mainstream news.
It's on TV all the time.
It's the images are flooding the Internet and the amount of press that's
covering it on TV in comparison to the Internet is still relatively small
because a huge percentage of the Internet is dedicated to the stories that are
going on down there.
The girl who you were talking about who is pregnant,
who miscarried the 89 year old or 84 year old woman that got pepper Seattle
face.
Yeah.
All these people that are getting beaten with clubs and and all the wild.
These protesters have been amazing.
They're just not,
they're not fighting back.
They're just there.
They're sitting there getting blasted in the face while they're on their knees
is calm.
I want to,
I'd love to see the,
the interview of a guy right after getting exposed on the Internet like that,
you know the job or it's just like,
ah shit.
I forgot.
People are watching all the time.
I don't think they have any idea how responsible people are going to hold them
for that.
How accountable people are going to hold them for that.
That got pepper sprayed.
All those kids in the face,
the pepper sprayed people's little girls and little boys because they were
protesting you,
motherfucker did you do?
Do we not learn anything from the sexual lives?
Just get ruined by that.
Yeah.
Other stories of that girl that had like a Vlog or live Ustream she was doing
and people just started just hating on her so hard and then her dad got involved
in embarrassed or even more and it just like their phones were going off the
hook.
I mean it was just so terrible,
but it just gets brutal.
Yeah,
the whole thing is brutal.
I mean it's like people are starting to take into consideration the very real
possibility that our civilization might be collapsing right in front of our face
and that this is just one step in,
uh,
and erosion of our current state of life or current.
You know,
our way of life,
you know,
and this is if there's no money in that,
things can't stay the same.
You can't have the same amount of food in the supermarkets and the same amount
of gas and what,
what is going to happen if it really gets to a point where our economy
collapses?
Does anybody really prepared to wait in line to buy food and to have like a loaf
of bread be 500 bucks or something he imagined,
you know what the fuck happens when it gets that bad?
Moved back home to mom and plant some tomatoes.
You got a definitely got to grow your own food.
But fuck is it becomes a question.
Like,
is it possible that I could slide that far back?
Because right now everybody's complaining and it does look terrible and yeah,
the government totally sucks.
But if things froze right here in time,
life ain't that bad.
You know,
right now we can get gas right now.
Uh,
I get on direct TV,
I got 250 channels.
My Internet is not the fastest in the world,
but it's a lot better than it was 10 years ago.
I've got my health,
you know what I'm saying?
Let's stop right here.
But you can't stop right here.
You can't stop right here because we're still in debt.
Who knows how many trillion dollars.
You're also so much more aware.
Yeah.
And then people were,
oh yeah.
You know,
to where it was like they might not be aware of how bad things were at certain
points.
Well this a,
this is enough shocking information on the Internet right now where if you're
not concerned,
then you're simply not paying attention.
You know,
when you start reading about these 16 billion or trillion dollars in secret
bailouts,
they uncovered with an audit of the Fed,
16 trillion.
I don't even know how many Zeros that is,
but that's an insane,
I know that's more than the gross domestic product product to the entire United
States.
And that was all given out.
And the bailouts,
he's no interest loans all secretly,
uh,
an approved,
it's a God damn money grab man.
It's a money grab and there's a reason why these people are in the street and it
ain't just because they're hippies cause there's a lot of them that are there
just because they're hippies,
you know,
they would be there if it was,
a flower festival or a grateful dead tribute band,
you know,
they would,
they would be there.
I wonder if there's also been like homeless people that have just been like,
yeah,
they're fucking psyched or the place,
yes,
there's a place for me to stay.
Of course you're definitely going to have that.
But on top of that you've got a lot of really intelligent people.
What's really interesting is the difference.
There was a video that I watched yesterday on how Fox News covered the tea party
and how they're covering this and the tea party they were describing as a grass
roots movement with no discernible a leader who,
and it all came together organically there essentially describing occupy Wall
Street.
But there were,
there were saying it will the mainstream media cover this.
That's the real question.
Like,
and I'm watching this like what the fuck are you,
you fox?
You know,
this isn't some underground new sources sneaking out the information to the
brave men and women of America.
So skewed.
There's there Fox and they're,
they're pretending that they're not the mainstream media.
You're not there.
Not only are they covering the tea party,
but they're promoting it there.
The people are fed up and you know what I think I see their point and they,
you know,
they're editorializing as they're given this news.
And then they were talking about occupy Wall Street and they were saying that
it's not going to last and there's no,
there's no message behind and you can't find one person.
And then they have videos.
It showed videos of intelligent people explaining what's wrong,
explaining what they're trying to accomplish and explaining how they're going to
go about doing it.
And they didn't use any of that shit on TV,
any of it.
And then,
you know,
he showed all the videos that people have done.
Like there's this one guy,
I forget his name,
but he's brilliant.
He goes to Sarah Pailin book signings.
He goes to the tea party things in the interviews and he clowned something.
We just get some to eat.
They don't even know.
He's not,
he's,
they don't even know that he's filming like a parody.
They don't even know that he's,
you know,
just going to get them to say really stupid shit and show how a different
costumes they're just think,
just wears a tie.
And I forget what his name is.
I'm really doing him a disservice because he's hilarious.
Um,
but my point was it's easy to find just a few people and use those people to
discredit the tea party.
I use those people discredit occupy Wall Street or whatever.
But when you got a movement that's as big as this fucking thing is,
they showed a picture of,
uh,
New York City where the,
the occupy movement was going on and that you see like how many people were
there.
It is gigantic,
man.
Yeah,
it's huge.
It's gigantic.
It was like a shot from the helicopter.
I went with him.
I haven't seen what it's like now.
I
was,
I went there like a month ago and saw,
you know what it was at that point.
It's bigger,
it's bigger,
you know,
I mean,
it's really amazing that,
uh,
his little violence has happened,
you know,
really is,
it's really kind of incredible.
He's really using the product.
He's going to go crazy right now.
He's feeling stupid.
It's fill all stupid.
He's worried that one of the Illuminati come.
He might not have enough brains.
Get out of the way.
You know,
it's the real question for me about all this is not whether or not it's going to
grow,
because it's definitely going to grow.
People are loving it.
They're loving it.
They're,
they're,
they have a voice.
People feel like for the longest time,
you know,
they know that they've been fucked.
They know that the government has been inept and using their tax dollars.
They know that laws have been passed that benefit.
Corporations only,
and not people at all.
They know that all this has happened,
but they haven't been able to do anything about it.
And they have this pent up shit inside of them,
and now they're standing in the street altogether and they feel like they're
getting something done just by getting their,
their voice out.
But the problem is unemployment's band,
it's not going to get any better,
and this isn't gonna go away.
It's going to get bigger.
And people are gonna start wanting results.
They're going to start wanting something to happen.
Well,
somebody should probably step forward at some point as I spoke.
I mean,
you know,
yeah,
I don't think so.
I don't think anybody will,
but I think that would don't think right guy came out.
I mean,
yeah,
but I don't think they examine anonymous mass gone.
He's going to take it off and it's Obama and modern day.
Whoa.
Imagine that.
Holy Shit,
John Lennon.
Imagine it.
It was Obama who was working at both sides.
That'd be a great movie in the basement of best buy.
It's like at this round table and they all take off their anonymous mask and
it's all like Ronald Reagan and he's turning to Sanders and his dead.
Bob Hope,
Bob Hope.
And then that is a fucking great idea for a movie though.
President Brandon Walsh president gets into office and really thinks he's going
to be the president.
He thinks he's going to get in there and he's going to fix things and he's going
to change the world.
And then once he gets in there,
he has to deal with all these special interest groups in the military.
Industrial Complex and all these creepy flux that are essentially starting wars
for profit and there's no way around it.
He can't,
he has to stick to the agenda.
It's that money that got him into office in the first place,
but he'll cover designs.
He designs occupy Wall Street and he's a part of anonymous and he's attacking it
from the inside and providing them with information.
This is the movie and they can fly and they can make gold out of poop.
That's got to be got to vote for this guy.
Yeah.
It's good to be Herman Cain
with his wink and it's smoking friend Herman Cain.
Celeris.
I liked it.
He likes white chicks though.
Trying to hit up on some white chucks.
Got Boston.
Yeah,
I hit that.
I haven't,
no one's actually come forward for though.
I thought that they got people,
not a bad looking older lady.
Neighbors came forward.
Okay.
No Herman Cains girl came forward to at least one of them.
I think a couple of them come forth.
It's whatever of people like said something,
but then they never made it official.
If Kennedy had tried to run for president today,
nobody can have flaws anymore.
It's like we were talking about with Julian Assange's.
Yeah.
He dances like a creep and he'd probably stuck it in that girl when they were
lying next to each other,
but she shouldn't have been sleeping with him in the first place.
You know?
What are you doing naked laying next to Julian Assange?
Anything at any point could come back and bite you.
Yeah,
the whole thing is weird.
That's the internet just can make it harder and harder for people to get.
It's so true though,
that they can lock this guy up.
You know,
that's not what you're mad at him for,
but you're mad at him for releasing all those secrets.
But what he did is really what a real journalist is supposed to do.
You know,
I mean,
someone said to,
to him,
um,
what would be the difference between,
you know,
this information coming from you or coming from the New York Times and you know,
and what he said was,
I'm not exactly sure the New York Times.
I think you said this.
Maybe there's somebody else said this,
I'm,
I don't want to quote him.
Essentially it wasn't Ziggy.
Um,
but essentially what they were saying was,
um,
he might be the only group that would just release all of it.
Whereas if that,
that material was sent to the Washington Post,
or if that material was sent to any legitimate quote unquote corporate sponsored
major new shores,
they,
you're supposed to release that information like the video of the,
um,
the Apache,
those,
whatever those helicopters shooting those,
those kids in the car and those people that are on the street.
And I was innocent people.
I mean that,
that's the way they were talking about it.
They shouldn't have brought their kids like it was,
it was dark.
You know,
there's kids that should,
should've brought their kids like up,
right?
Like they're not,
they didn't feel bad about it at all.
And the fact that this is,
these are American soldiers and this is,
it's possible to get to this mindset.
That's a very important fact for us to know as a nation.
They're very,
we should be informed to make our decisions about how we truly feel about war,
you know?
And if we're shielding the public from information like that,
in my opinion,
that is like treason.
That is like,
that's like espionage.
That's like you're,
you're shielding important information.
Just to think about how many,
I mean the possibilities of how unreal these stories can be that nobody will
ever know that are just always being bought and hidden.
And I'm sure,
yeah,
I mean at any point could just come out when you hear all,
I mean there's been several instances of,
especially the black water and other soldiers being accused of killing
civilians.
It's like,
it's not one instance,
it's several.
There's another guy who got arrested recently and they were,
they were saving fingers and shit and killing civilians.
You know,
when you hear about these instances that it not everyone's getting caught.
Okay.
There's some people that are pulling shit off and they're getting away with it
and they have to cover it up.
But then every now and then someone would go crazy and kill like 20 or 30 people
and then they have to,
you know,
they have a situation,
I mean it's,
it's,
it's very dark.
It's very dark.
You're asking people to kill people.
You're asking people to kill and then you're going to let them just roam free in
the population.
Like someone who's never killed before as it remind me of the people I can
Bourne identity that are the ones that are always trying to kill Jason Bourne
that has keep hiring like another guy.
I don't watch those movies.
You don't shut it.
Oh God,
I love him.
I'm not in breast with his Jujitsu.
I like watching those moves.
I don't believe it.
You should write.
You should watch it with Pete Holmes stopped watching Dexter because he did a
bad jujitsu move during the best season with John.
Lithgow has a shitty rear naked choke.
Okay.
Shitty.
And it's not how you,
it's not what happens when he choke somebody out.
God,
if you were to watch Dexter now,
you would just fall asleep.
It's horrible.
Even that directing is,
I can't tell cause I just got used to watching a show and then cause I like
Michael see hall's character so much.
I just don't like what's going on around him.
And he got sick too.
That's when it was weird too.
[inaudible] is married to the girl that plays anymore.
They broke up
scenes together.
It's so weird.
Yeah,
it's weird knowing that they boned and they're playing with brothers and sisters
on the show and [inaudible] heart is broken.
Well that's what I mean.
Like I'm a dumb fucking the career move,
isn't it?
I mean that's a really silly move,
Dude.
Fuck.
Would you,
do you remember their kids remember like what happened to his wife and he has
kids,
you know,
like he does,
he has kids on the show.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The girl,
they don't even exist anymore.
Like they don't,
they haven't talked about him all season.
They were the grandparents forever.
They went to the grandparents.
They don't talk.
It's your kid.
You would talk to him every day.
He's got that boy though.
Made me sexy.
She's sexy in some weird kind of crazy bitch way.
Is there a water I can grab in there?
Yeah.
What do you want man?
Hold on one.
Want water,
diet coke,
energy drink coconut water,
coconut water.
You got us the C two I love that stuff.
Especially cold.
So do you.
I went to a party,
it was a benefit for a hope field,
which is an annual thing and I saw some,
they had,
it was a small low party and they had some of the best musicians there ever.
Women Singing Natasha Bedingfield is there.
Natasha Bedingfield.
She's the one I think that sings the song to the hills.
Oh,
so this was like a big time.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
This is like all ace celebrities there.
And I talked to Jeremy Pivot.
He said he wants to do the podcast.
I Leona Lewis was the main girl.
But you know after seeing them it was so amazing to get off stage that I was
like in love.
Like I was obsessed with these,
these female singers.
Do you get that?
Cause you played guitar on stage a lot.
Do you get your version of Fan doing comedy and guitar?
You'd probably get it messy.
Slang that,
yeah.
Yeah.
They do sling it out.
There's a lot of slinging.
Yeah.
There's a lot of rubber.
No,
I don't.
I find with the,
you know,
especially comedy nerds,
they're not necessarily out front.
It's not like I'm in a band.
It's a whole different audience.
I'm making myself.
I'm making a fool of myself essentially.
Whereas they're just continually looking cool the whole time they're out there.
Yeah.
It's totally different.
Sexual vibe.
Girls love to laugh though.
Playing a song that's a whole different kind of hypnotizing now,
even if it is a joke or making fun of yourself,
it's something that adds to it.
And we were talking about Leonard Skinner being fat dirty white guys from
Florida,
but they knew how to make some sound.
They know how to make some sounds that are delicious.
They're delicious.
The cars,
like you see these bands that the way they look.
I mean it's still,
yeah,
it's sexy.
I mean,
Rick,
I find myself attracted to girl to her,
you know,
any that are just talented like that doesn't matter.
Do you find yourself sexually attracted to them?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Wears off though after your bone them.
Oh,
I'm sure there was a girl.
Oh yeah.
I'm sure it's got it.
It only gets happened that that's happened with almost every girl that except my
wife,
but yeah,
it does the,
every time I see a girl singing it just turns me on.
I can't help it.
I just want her.
Yeah.
For a lot of dudes either becomes a con.
Is that what it is,
the confidence to sit down in front of him and performed?
Reform.
Yeah.
God that that one chick though.
I'm seriously in love with Leona Lewis,
like I was just,
she's going to find out about it and she's going to put a restraining order and
I don't care.
You're going to be sitting in the front row and she's going to choke and she's
going to,
their voice is going to cry.
I do.
You know what she looks like?
Have you ever seen her fucking gorgeous?
What's her name?
Leona Lewis.
And she pulled a picture of this music.
Twitter knew a comedian named Leanne Lewis.
She,
she,
she did this whole thing though for this hope field.
She did this whole thing,
I guess it's like a place I get horses that are sick and stuff like that and
they have like 200 horses and this place is about to close because there was
bankrupt.
And so all these horses are just going to get euthanized.
And so that's why she's,
she,
she did this party to raise money for it.
And uh,
so here's,
I think I retweeted something about that.
Here's so suddenly,
you know.
But yeah,
it was cool.
There was a lot of interesting people at the,
just looks like a real woman.
Brian,
you might want to stay away from her.
Oh,
she,
she was,
what's your girlfriend do you said earlier?
She and the adult industry.
Yeah.
She's uh,
she's what?
Penthouse pet.
Oh,
okay.
Veronica Ricci.
She does those girl and girl.
Girl.
Girl video.
Oh,
that's it.
Yeah.
They get them in the dark side.
That how they come in and they get stuck in word doc of videos and then take
action videos with your boyfriend.
Why she both?
Huh?
Yeah.
Well she,
she loves doing that kind of that kind of like tie up stuff,
spanking videos and stuff like that.
Like I,
that's another one like it would,
there would have been a video of me like spanking her.
So do you guys do that?
A lot of spanking.
She's fuck no,
because her butt's always healing and she's always pretty like lotions on it and
stuff.
I don't want to rehearse it.
Yeah.
When it's outside of work,
she doesn't like getting spanked at all.
It's like,
God,
what am,
I was like,
no,
she still likes her.
Butt's always healing or feel bad for it.
Have you ever seen that?
A black,
but like two days later it looks like if she keeps on getting in a car accident
and her,
but really,
yeah,
it's just purple.
So they just fucking whale it on it.
Hard
Dude.
And the other girl had to go through that for punishment.
Shane Finer.
This girl named Jane Fonda,
she,
she's just spanking,
spanking her with like brushes.
Brushes are the worst,
I guess.
Who's ringing you?
That's not me.
Dammit.
I thought she got it.
It was
um,
talked to Perez Hilton was there and the whole time he's with these two girls
and this guy and his party and being very,
uh,
just staring at every buddy and he wasn't very friendly man.
He's probably got people fucking with him all day,
man.
I know.
I was just came,
I just said Hi.
You would seem very leaning into the gay bash real quick,
you know,
you know probably people who fuck with them all day.
Man.
He's probably in probably,
he also likes to stare at people and I mean that's what he does is he's kind of
a voyeur podcast guy,
right?
Show Perez Hilton knows that guy for the his website.
He's going to be huge or not podcast.
Yeah.
Judge website is nice.
Do you know Ron Ron?
A test?
I think this is his name.
He's,
I bet.
I bet guys would have been nice if he knew who you were for you.
You got a chance to talk to him among someone who you knew or he knew,
you know,
so he can see you were green lit or otherwise you're just some weird guy.
Hey Prez.
Hey,
how are ya?
You gotta be,
you gotta be glad handed into somebody's.
The pivot was a nice guy.
Heaven was awesome and I feel like me,
you and pivot all look like we're related.
Sometimes Callan,
Callan counts as good buddy.
That's how I know it was weird talking to,
I have this picture of him in,
it looks just like we're brothers.
It's kind of creepy.
Did you take it home and mountain?
Uh,
yeah.
It's framed and then just close your eyes and a wish.
Wish.
Wish she was my brother.
I think pivoting is super nice.
He's one of those guys that played such horrible characters all the time that
you think he's just going to be an asshole.
But he's,
he's so nice.
Well,
you know,
I mean,
I'm sure he's a mercurial character.
Is he like as a character?
I just very,
very nice.
Just a nice normal guy.
Oh,
it says low battery.
10% of battery male.
Yeah.
I see.
You're both dressed.
Oh yeah,
the same.
We don't give people my phone cause I black cock reasons.
Oh it was a what?
Prank pranks.
There's a prank that all of these comics play.
They always grab their phone like,
Oh let me see that picture.
And then they prank.
I love black cock on Twitter real quick when they're looking at the picture and
make it look like they're using your phone to look at a picture.
But somebody did that once where they like,
they came into my house and they went on my computer and posted something on
Facebook and,
and it's just like,
you know that's actually a,
I think that was like a privacy thing.
You just broke like a privacy law.
I think that might be illegal.
Is it illegal to someone to just come in and just,
yeah,
use a computer really.
And your mom follows you on Facebook and she's reading.
Why do people,
I keep on talking to people that let their mom on their Facebook page.
Why don't you make a fake Facebook page for your parents and family?
Like I do and I think everyone should do well because it then at some point you
can,
I mean I have one that's not my real name,
but it just isn't as fun.
People don't compliment me all the time.
There's a friend of mine that I photo shopped his face on balls a long time ago.
This was my space,
not Facebook and like it was just his face.
It like I made it so like his face matched into the balls.
It looked like just balls with his face on it.
It was kind of cool and a video that I sent you the yeah,
it wouldn't open up for me.
I was on my phone that when I checked it.
But yeah,
I was going to,
I'll tell you that.
But uh,
so I put it on his myspace page as a joke and he got really pissed off.
They do.
My Grandmother fucking saw that.
Yeah.
Photo.
What the fuck is your grandmother doing on mice?
Your mind space when we make sure that you're okay Sonny.
I know there's a lot of band influenced
and they look,
they like everything that you post,
ms legs,
my status updates,
what's wrong?
My mom will mow right things.
It's hilarious.
She writes,
she knew your Facebook?
No,
no,
no.
On her own little wall.
Yeah.
When that little friends,
we'll chime in.
What's going on with this country?
That's the full quote is no like there's no thought and need that it's like I'm
not comfortable.
Why?
It doesn't seem good.
I don't think they know.
They also,
they think they're just having a
station with like one person.
They don't understand that everybody is sees everything.
Yeah,
but I mean she only has a few friends on her Facebook.
I'm going to not like,
he's got thousands and should not a comedian,
you know?
It's just,
most of it is like that's how they keep up with family members and tag pictures
and stuff.
Family,
family.
People love Facebook because it's so sort of,
it's all integrated in a way that myspace never is.
My space is just,
everybody has their own websites and there's a comments.
The stream of information,
like Bobby just updated his blog post.
Oh,
Debbie just posted a picture and you know when they do that then everybody feels
like they're,
they're moving together.
I like Instagram.
That's my new favorite thing.
What's that?
It's just pictures.
It's like posting statuses but just pictures so you don't feel like it to be
funny all the time.
That a long time ago,
text America,
it's frag mob.
It's my fake Facebook page for my mom and my parents and my family and stuff.
Like I'll just purposely like I'll be sitting there and I'm like,
oh look a rose and I'll take a photo of it and then I'll post that kind of shit
on my Facebook.
Like,
look,
I rose was living a lie.
Yeah.
It's like a huge,
like I'm just this pure guy that's taken photos of puppies and stuff like that.
How many people have a bunch of different aliases online?
That's what gets rid of that because one of the guys from our a message board
was worried that his wife was a on a cougar website.
It turns out they like just ganged her pictures for somewhere.
Yeah.
I wonder how often that happens.
It happens a lot.
Maltipoo I
met him up in Canada,
but it was really fascinating because,
you know,
he was kind of joking around and I'm pretty sure he's happily married and
everything's good,
everything like that.
But he's like,
well,
either one of two things is going on.
Either my wife is really on fucking cougar life.com or whatever website it was.
Or I'm getting a fucking divorce,
you know,
like how could you imagine it?
Why should they Madison?
Well that's what is that?
It's the same thing,
but Ashley Madison is like the one where it's like set up for cheating,
right?
Yeah.
So he's just,
just,
everybody gets together and go,
I'm going to be Jason Bourne and you'd be fucking Tonya Harding and let's do
this.
I heard it's turn interviewing that guy.
And it was like,
so what do people do that they go under fake names now?
They just put their,
I mean,
I didn't,
yeah,
they must do aliases.
Like so popular.
I mean he was giving us statistics and it's all people cheating.
Well really it's all people that are down to fuck is what it is.
Right?
No questions asked.
Get a fake ring and pretend you're married and so he can just be a swinger and
just go in there and let these girls know there's no commitment here and just
bang it out real quick.
That unfortunately I bet there's way more guys than girls and there's like seven
girls that keep on getting reused by the hundred [inaudible].
There was a lot less long as you get yours happy.
It took over for craigslist because craigslist stopped being,
it's cracked.
Let's kind of straighten itself out.
Turn itself away from all the sex stuff.
Really what the fuck is that?
Well,
if they don't want to get in trouble for prostitution,
there's probably kind of liabilities that they can be like torn so tired of this
nanny state we're living in.
As I become a a middle aged man,
I mean I'm essentially a middle aged man.
I'm 44 years old.
How many people lived over 88 you know,
I'm probably way past the middle,
right?
This is at a certain point in time,
we just want to go.
Just shut the fuck up.
This is stupid.
We have too many God damn laws.
It's really that simple.
You can't regulate craigslist.
Jesus Christ.
He can't regulate.
If a girl has an ad and she says,
listen,
I need money.
You need a blow job,
what the fuck,
man,
that's,
that's a legitimate exchange.
That's what that is.
I mean,
why?
Why is there anything wrong with that?
Yeah.
I wouldn't encourage it.
I wouldn't want my kids to do it,
but if she wants to do it,
if she knows that she can go suck some guys deck and make 500 bucks or whatever
the hell it is,
why not?
Why?
Why do you care?
It's okay if she does it for free.
She could go over to the guy's house and knock on doors.
She could put on craigslist,
I'm here to fuck you for free.
Who wants to fuck if you could do that.
No problem.
And no one has a problem with,
it's just the exchanging of money.
Even if she put it on her taxes,
I suck this guy's Dick.
He gave me 500 bucks.
Uncle Sam,
here's your,
here's your buck 50 and we're good.
Right?
That would like to see a tax form.
Yeah.
All Day.
All Day or all day?
Yeah.
Why?
Um,
why,
why is that a problem man?
It's amazing.
It's amazing that that's a problem.
You know,
in other countries it's not an issue at all.
In Australia.
We were in Sydney and a,
the fucking cab driver's telling us,
I said,
you guys want to get some pussy right down the street.
Might there's a nice,
nice,
it's okay.
I don't know.
There's like an area where you go,
hmm.
I obviously
didn't go,
but there's a whole area where you can go and there's whorehouses there.
We have time.
It's no big deal.
We had from high times,
uh,
this girl named Sarah Hash Newton,
I and she hash Hash is her name Hash Newton.
Is that a real name?
I think the Hashtag Hashtag maybe that's like our favorite cook that the hash of
a fig Newton a dash no hash come up now that's over the top.
But I call myself Joe Comedy Rogan.
She saw him show comedy.
She's so hot,
but it's like high times is like penthouse pet and he's like their version of,
but she was talking about how there was a picture.
Yeah,
I can get her ready.
Sarah,
her name,
she's on Twitter.
Sarah Hash Newton.
All one word.
[inaudible] are in her underwear or something.
Scanty I could find you something.
Definitely scantily clad.
Like right now you say you're on this podcast.
People are now checking out her page.
Probably.
Yeah,
of course.
Oh Dude.
We crashed websites like a motherfucker on this podcast when we had Graham
Hancock.
God,
you know Graham Hancock is this a world famous explorer who's written all these
books about ancient civilizations and really fascinating guy.
He's also written a bunch of books on psychedelic drugs or one rather really
bad.
Duncan told me about this guy.
Um,
and yeah,
Dunkin did the podcast with me and we just crushed this website.
I couldn't get to anything.
He was trying to show me some structures that they found outside of Japan.
Some amazing stuff there.
Like shows that there was a complex civilization that lived there 14,000 years
ago,
which is according to archaeologists,
it's like before people,
I mean people were like hunter gatherers back then.
That's like the guy that,
I love that this guy,
this British guy that was like lost in the Amazon,
they never found his body.
And there's a book that just came out about it in the last,
the Z Z or something,
but it's a great story,
but it's about,
uh,
this lost civilization.
Well,
the Amazon is filled with them.
You know,
they're just starting to find all these structures that are hidden underneath a
jungle in the Amazon.
They say that in between the Mayan civilizations and the Incas and the old macs,
there are thousands and thousands of undiscovered temples that are all
throughout Mexico and South America that they really have no idea how many of
these things have just not been discovered.
Were civilization just the plants just grew over them.
It seems like it'd be so easy to find out Google.
Yeah,
I think so.
You think she'd have that mapped out?
Yeah,
I mean,
some of them.
I looked at this one temple did the excavated in Mexico and it's fucking
incredible.
They had pictures of it before they ask evaded it and it looked like just a
hill.
It was like a hill and it literally had been completely covered in dirt for the
how many thousands and thousands of years it took to do that,
you know?
I mean,
who knows?
Who knows how long it takes for something to be covered in dirt naturally.
But there was no,
no sign whatsoever.
And then they cleared it out and it's fucking amazing.
Just huge Mayan temples.
Damn.
She met you at the 2007 high times a word.
Sarah Hope.
I was friendly.
It was real quick.
She knows that I'm a dispensary,
that you can get
hand jobs in the back so you get weed in the front and jumps in the back.
Really?
Yeah.
Where's it at?
I don't know.
I didn't talk to her.
That's hilarious.
Let me just ask you to go to jail.
That's what it is.
That is the weed community is infiltrated with the Strip club community decided
to kill two birds for the price of one or something along those lines.
Another place that 2:00 AM was connected to a strip club.
Right?
There you go.
Maybe it's the same guy.
He's branched off to this new hand job operation.
So what's,
let's get to the point.
What do people want?
Pot,
pot and loads.
Don't want loads come out to dick.
We could do that one in the front and the other in the back.
That's jobs in the back.
Okay.
Yeah.
Some do.
Some dude's will not cheat on their wives,
but they will go and get jerked off.
I know a bunch of dudes still go to massage places and get jerked off.
It's definitely a weird thing where it at it somebody is making you come.
What's going on?
I mean,
I could see the strip clubs,
the wine strip clubs,
not really cheating.
You're just sitting there.
You're not really supposed to grab unless it's a really skanky place.
So you're just sitting there and they're rubbing on Ya and then you give them
money and they leave.
It's a gray area,
but I think you could slide at the point where somebody puts their hands down
your pants.
It seems like that you're basically,
it shouldn't be really.
It should be that.
It does is a push.
That's what it should be.
Everyone's giving you the,
okay.
I mean maybe those guys,
their wife's like,
Hey,
go get your drug dog.
When you got to do,
well,
there was a story about a woman in England and her husband and a twisted Dick is
dick was weird or something wrong with it and it was painful for her.
The way her vagina was built and the way his dick was built didn't like it.
So he just went to hookers and she was cool with it.
You know,
she didn't want sex.
She was good with it.
She was kind of fat and they just had this done.
She shut the box down so over was like,
go ahead,
go shoot those loads over time.
As long as you come back home,
cuddle up with me.
That's it.
That's interesting to cuddle that in the end,
she just wants the intimacy.
While some people don't want sucks anymore,
you know,
that is a fact.
I mean,
there are relationships like that where the man or the woman,
either one of them has decided they don't want sex anymore.
It's almost always usually a woman.
Right.
But then there's a weird ones where the man wants other guys to fuck his wife.
You know?
There's,
there's a lot of those weird ones.
Yeah,
that's a,
those are the people that hang out at comedy
or painting it like a picture.
Like that's all.
Now there's like one week,
maybe it may be if that,
it's just,
you know what it is.
Comedy clubs are magnets for people that live,
you know,
sort of outside the norm of society.
You know,
they're magnets for people that,
you know,
they're just living in different,
they're drinking all the time.
They're going out,
they're partying.
They're not prudes or not waking up in the morning to get up early to go to
church.
You know,
they're not,
there's definitely that to a corporate job.
Does regulars that come through that they're like,
hey this,
there's the one guy that comes every Saturday.
He gets really loud,
but just,
he's a regular,
well,
how about the Hollywood regular?
It's like Johnny's App.
You know,
guys like that guys have become a part of the scene.
they're essentially fans that would come almost always by themselves.
Yeah.
Right.
And just come and just,
I don't think everybody that anybody ever charged him for tickets.
Right.
He just came and sat down.
It was like he was one of the guys,
you know,
cause he take no,
no,
no.
Jesus.
Same Way.
There's one guy that sits down and takes note,
like he'll write down a joke when he thinks it's funny.
You mean Hollywood?
Jesus,
the guy who walks with a cross
guided walks around it.
It looks like Jesus because his mom was really religious.
I think the story is that,
and his mom was really religious and then she died.
So when she died,
yeah,
he decided to honor her mom by dressing up as Jesus.
So he grew his beard out and he looks just like Jesus and he just walks down,
you know,
throughout Hollywood.
He just hangs out at the comedy store.
He's in tons of movies and stuff like that.
He's just known for being Hollywood.
Jesus.
He has like a Twitter and everything.
It's cool.
Wow.
Fuck the real cool guy.
What you did is so cool though that one of the nicest guys ever.
Yeah,
it's getting some followers.
So he just goes to the comedy store and hang things out.
Yeah,
there's a bunch of guys.
The comedy store is a magnet for crazy people.
The years,
years that we were there filming stuff and the back.
Oh my God.
It was like always every day it was like some news gives a phrenic or a
prostitute wanted to talk about how she got customers.
Remember that prostitute,
she want to talk to us in depth about,
uh,
you know how she quit and she didn't mind that we were filming.
It was so weird.
How often do you go there?
I don't go there at all anymore.
Or you don't go anywhere now.
I stopped going there a long time ago.
I haven't been there since the [inaudible].
Oh,
that's,
oh.
I thought maybe that that was just done and you went back.
No,
no,
no.
They can go.
Fuck.
Now we could hit that.
Pasadena Ice House in Pasadena is infinitely better.
It's so much better vibe.
Everybody there is nice.
There's no Tommy,
there's no douche genus.
There's no people don't appreciate the artists.
There's no dark overlord.
It's a completely different sort of a setup and now we all have a man cave.
We just hang out.
They have the coolest style.
I love that bat cave and he's seen the podcast,
the room now studio.
Now Brian set up a whole studio.
That's where you're,
oh yeah.
You're saying that the place where they used to run out too.
It's awesome.
We do shows that we do an 85 seat room,
which is awesome.
It's really intimate and that side room.
Perfect.
That's the weird little little funky room,
so it's easy to fill.
We fill it in just for people on Twitter and we all have a good time.
We hang out,
we do the podcast.
We shoot the shit and you know,
and when you're doing the podcast,
you're sort of joking around and cracking on things and it just goes right down
to the stage just like it's a great warmup.
Yeah.
Like one person gets on stage,
one pixel gets off and you just switch it off.
Like tomorrow we have Steevo,
Joey Diaz and his life.
A bunch of friends.
If you weren't in Portland,
Oregon,
you could come down with us or not.
That's the 30th Oh,
okay.
What are you doing tomorrow?
Going to San Francisco.
That's his,
that's his family that's trying to get you in,
Bro.
I want to come out.
You leaving for Thanksgiving?
Yeah.
Your family lives in San Francisco and my wife's sister,
San Francisco.
It's pretty dope.
Yeah.
I can't wait.
It's pretty good fucking,
it's my first time not going back to Seattle,
like going home.
You know,
if I was going to live in a city city,
like congested sort of type city,
San Francisco would be the one.
I would prefer that.
Here you aren't there.
Yeah.
You could live in a house.
You could be in the city and still live in a house,
you know it's prayerless parking.
The weather's decent you to get deal with the winter.
I mean it's Kinda chilly and foggy,
but you also,
you have way more um,
culture.
Then la has people are more interesting.
People seem to be more intelligent,
less Hollywood types,
less showbiz times.
There's a vapid nature to la that's really not like anywhere else in the country
and people are moving there a lot.
I think they're in San Francisco.
Portland are really big cities to move to.
Yeah.
I would say I would take San Francisco report lessons just because of the rain
thing I could,
I love Portland though.
It's sunny here in Portland.
Portland.
Does it rain like Seattle?
Oh,
it doesn't?
No.
Really?
I don't know man.
I talked to Sally a bit.
No,
it's still,
it still has,
it's not like living in La.
It's still has its times,
but,
but it's not as bad as it gets.
Yeah,
it gets more sun.
How many more days?
10 yeah,
maybe more.
Maybe 10 maybe 10
okay.
It's not that much.
I'll tell you what though,
man,
when we were there,
the grass was fucking green.
It was vibrant and alive.
And you're like,
you see grass in la,
it's like barely hanging on grass in la.
It looks like an like an old lady that's got enough rain this year to where
there is some good grass in places that haven't seen him lately lately,
but in Seattle and you know in Oregon,
those sorts of mains and evergreen state God.
And you see the fucking rivers there and shit.
So gorgeous man.
It's like I would,
I would,
I don't,
might be willing to take that trade off for the,
the way they have those rain forests up there.
The forest are so dense mass and I seem to get out there,
but there's the forest here too are incredible.
Yeah,
there's some pretty not that far out of town or going up to big bear.
It's so close and it feels like you're kinda out dude.
Big Bears.
That shit,
that whole area.
Lake Arrowhead,
big bear,
all those mountains right down.
You know.
Um,
I was reading about fucking a Lyme disease man.
I know Louis Ck had some bit when he was talking about,
um,
uh,
his wife got bit by a tick and got Lyme disease and they get it from deer.
And uh,
I forget who the guy was,
some famous guy,
but he also got Lyme disease and it really FAU hall from Holland notes.
Oh yeah.
And the Lyme disease really fucked him up,
man.
They didn't catch it in time.
So a apparently Lyme disease,
if you catch it quick,
you're okay.
You know they have medicine.
What's the symptoms?
I don't know.
That's a good question.
But if you're around a lot of places where deer,
it affects your kidney or something or really fucks you with tiny never
organ.
Yeah.
Got To kill him,
kill him all.
Don't you worry donors.
Why?
Why,
why we keep it around techs?
We need to figure out where to eradicate ticks.
Yeah.
I don't know if there's a way to dirty little cots biting you and giving you
those small,
hidden,
have you ever had a tick what's,
they'd have to serve?
Some sort of purpose.
My dog used to have them.
My one of my dogs,
I had a bunch of texts,
had problems,
and then we had to put other stuff on his body.
It's like chemical on his body that doesn't allow ticks to get on them.
You'd find them in is for like you'd pat them and then you'd find like these in
gorge spots where like did it be as swollen tick fill with blood and then you
have to burn it.
You have to burn it to get it off China.
One of the boys got,
I had one in my inner thigh and leg leader guy like took a match and put it on
there.
And then of course he had to suck the poison out of the thigh.
He really
did.
He think of your butthole is behind my ear,
but yeah,
you took a match to it.
So Nick Dune,
where are you come?
Where are you going in the,
in the future?
Where can people see ya?
Uh,
San Francisco.
The 29th where yet?
The punchline.
Nice.
Doing a reason.
Doing the reunion tour.
Reuniting with myself for three shows.
Portland,
the 30th,
Seattle,
the first at even where in Portland.
And we're in Seattle,
helium in Portland on the 30th and then Seattle at theater.
And so if they go to Nick thune.com where they can find a nickname that to get
inflammation go down powerful.
We like,
we should promote like a Brennan Walsh show.
Just to clear my just,
and let's promote that show I was and wash up a website.
Brendan is,
uh,
should I should know this.
He was actually just up and see how yeah,
I can't remember.
You had to.
Seattle shows can be fun too.
I want to let me going back to my hometown.
It's the first time in three years you started doing stand up there to do that.
A comedy underground,
the underground and,
and um,
I didn't play there.
That was the first time I ever featured was for Tom Rhodes there.
Oh really?
Oh that's awesome.
But then there's this place giggles that I kind of start playing that too.
That was jiggle.
It's silly.
It wasn't a part of Seattle.
It's not there anymore.
I remember Mitch Hedberg had a great joke about it though,
that he was like passed along to the local comedians because Mitch used to go
out there a lot and it was uh,
the guy that,
the guy that books is place washes his straws.
That's how cheap he has.
What?
I didn't know,
I could imagine it,
but he would basically take tickets at the door seat people and then be the
waiter.
Oh my God.
I mean he ran the whole place.
He was a monster.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
How many people did the seat?
Sometimes he would even host the show to Gog.
Some guys like to host shows their own club.
There was a guy in Memphis that insisted on bringing up Joey Diaz.
I'm like,
I'm,
I'll just go up and bring up Joey and then Joey and bring me up some bar.
And the guy wanted to go up and like you could tell they get all jazzed up for
it and the one on stage to fuck,
fuck yeah do.
Julia was mad.
What the fuck's going on?
How come you're not bringing me up?
What's this guy bring me up?
Just fucking Momo.
I wonder how long ago that guy was a comic then?
What point?
He was just like,
yeah,
just by a club.
It's a lot of them like that in some spot back in Boston.
A bunch of the guys,
Barry Katz,
Billy Downs and Paul Barclay like two of the,
one of the biggest agents in two of the,
one of the biggest managers and two of the biggest booking agents and uh,
uh,
clubs rather in the,
in the whole area buried.
Yeah,
Barry started,
I was just standing around buried and bill downs and Paul Barclay,
they're the guys that owned the comedy connection and then duck and then they
opened up the comic connection at Faneuil Hall and then they eventually got out
of the business altogether.
But they started out as comedians and they were like the number one guys in
Boston for awhile.
They even books shows outside of their clubs.
The thing about Boston was like,
you know,
like you go to the comedy store,
the comic store books,
comic store and that's it.
They have that.
They don't have a comedy store in Boston,
do they know?
But the comedy store is comedy store here and they have a comedy store in La
Jolla.
But the way a lot of clubs work,
like in Boston you would,
they would have like a bunch of little satellite rooms.
They would book also because he would call them up and you would say,
you know,
hey,
you got anything for me.
And they would say,
hey,
we got this gig down the Cape,
you know,
it's a Friday night,
it's 150 bucks.
And the laugh factory does that.
They have like three or four weekly shows that they kind of book out and bars
and stuff like that.
That's a smart thing to do.
And I know one of them is by that fucking guy with the red hair who was from
Boston.
What the Hell's his name?
Steve Hofstetter.
No,
I don't remember.
I forgot it.
Uh,
but that,
that style of a,
you know,
having like comedy nights and,
and,
and bars and stuff like that,
that's what really builds up a comedy community.
If there's a bunch of different places where guys can work,
it's fun to go out.
I mean those,
those shows are always hit or miss.
I mean some of them are awesome.
Some can be great.
Yeah.
Have a great moment in a room like that.
As long as they're set up right.
As long as the sound system is allowing the stages good.
Those are the two important factors.
Sometimes he'll go like,
there's like that room down in like a San Diego that I used to do a lot and I
haven't done it forever but or like moon doggies.
Oh yeah.
Joey does go down at all.
It's a good entity.
Moon doggies.
And it was a rough shot.
I mean they've got like a fireplace in the back and the walls open and people
are smoking and it's a party.
Someone like me and it's quiet.
Yeah.
You play your attention when you play music all the time and all your shows.
Do you do it?
Not the whole show.
No,
but sometimes you do some sets,
like when you go to a club,
you do some sets with no music at all.
Right?
No,
I'll around town.
When I planted,
when I plan a la,
I'll go up to the laugh factory with nothing.
But if I'm headlining a show on the road at brand new guitar and it's like a
portion of the show,
there was a time Mitzi shore,
I forget who it was onstage,
but there was a guy who was a of music act and he was trying to bring your,
you're funny,
you're,
you have a music act on top of the funny,
but the music act isn't a crutch.
You know,
you're just a good musician that happens to use it in a standup comedy routine.
But like,
I remember one time I,
uh,
I texted you,
I was in my car and I was listening to XM comedy was the raw dog comedy,
whatever it is.
Oh,
Rhonda.
And uh,
this guy was really funny.
I was like,
who the fuck is this guy?
I'm like,
this guy is really funny.
And it was you.
Oh really?
Yeah,
it was you.
I'm all right.
I remember you remember I texted you.
I wonder,
is that after we,
cause we did that.
Remember that Twitter show we did?
Yes,
yes.
Yeah.
Twice after that.
You're hanging out with [inaudible] we did it.
Yeah.
Our Twitter show chocolate rain.
[inaudible]
I forgot about that.
Yeah,
and crystal.
Leah,
I think it was like,
no,
it was um,
uh,
Doug Dove,
dove you,
me and there was one other person,
Ben Morrison.
What?
Yes.
Ben Was the guy who organized it.
Yeah.
Right.
So the acoustics were so bad.
Nick was on stage and I'm standing next to the stage.
I couldn't understand a fucking word.
He was saying echoey.
It was crazy.
It was set up for band.
What have you been room?
Was that in?
I mean,
that was,
it was a disco.
It was terrible.
It was some weird place,
downtown number.
It was like a weird colors in a warehouse where you would buy ecstasy from some
on a stairwell watching.
And I remember Ben Morrison,
it was like,
I'm going to go down and do like 10 minutes and then bring you up.
I'm like,
okay.
And he goes down and it doesn't meant,
and he's like,
all right,
well this is not working.
Let's bring up the one solid cock after another.
Each word.
He was saying they were just shoving cock deeper into his mouth.
He couldn't breathe after a minute.
He was eating shit up there.
Chocolate rain and I remember we got in trouble for smoking weed.
We opened up some doors to a balcony and smoke weed and I guess it's set off an
alarm.
I remember and then some guy came up there.
You guys didn't smoke weed,
you can't be smoking weed up here can be smoking weed.
We're in a warehouse and these are made for smoking weed.
That's what they're supposed to do.
You're not supposed to have alarms on your balconies.
Let 'em and smoke weed and privacy.
She's the least.
This is backstage.
Anything is possible.
How could you expect me to not be high when I'm doing the talk show?
Isn't that weird?
That was when it's wet echo bowl.
Twitter was like,
it was,
it was been out for awhile but just getting popular like that month that you
guys did that it was like that's when you alerted me to the magic of I Justine.
I didn't know that there was this girl named,
I just seen it has like a fucking hundred million youtube followers,
you know,
and she's got like well over a million and a half it last time I looked a
Twitter friends too.
Yeah,
she's got some crazy number,
something like that.
But I mean,
you know,
she gets online and she does like these little videos and she edits them.
That's the style of video on Youtube.
It's like a very short video where it's edited each and you can see the edits.
They're really clear blocks the head.
Who's got,
who's buying this stuff?
Not me.
I'll tell you.
Oh,
I'm gonna make it.
So with that fast information,
yeah,
but meanwhile it's getting people to pay attention to it.
I bet that check makes a lot of money because they have youtube ads and shit.
You know,
she's so hot.
You like her.
Is she your favorite of those kind of girls here?
Why is your phone,
whose phone is your phone?
It was not near the Cupola someone.
It has to be like right near the computer to make that known.
I had a text,
but that was seven minutes ago.
No,
it's Brian's ban.
It's that right there.
Yeah.
Why don't you to shut that bitch off once you get done?
It's doing it again.
It's not me to tell you what,
why is it,
what is going on?
When,
when the
car,
which I'm like driving your car,
right.
Actually turning mine off too.
It anywhere near a microphone because it's,
it,
it crosses paths with frank,
the frequency of the,
you know.
Okay.
Your eyes soundboard.
I'm making stuff up.
Your CD one one.
It's on Amazon thick noon.
Is that what it's called?
And you can get on Amazon and iTunes.
I actually listened to a couple of tracks.
I fucking awesome.
Oh,
thank you.
Very good.
You got voted best of 2010 or something like that.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
I think that they voted like tennis
best.
Oh,
that's cool.
But uh,
it was in that group of 10 nice.
Speaking of funny comics,
Jim Norton,
I read his Twitter.
He was tweeting the reverend Al Sharpton like over and over and over again.
It's really fucking flies.
Not,
yeah,
Norton.
He was like quoting shit that Al Sharpton has said.
He goes,
white folks was in caves while we was building empires and quotes and a Norton
goes,
well said,
please play that on your MSNBC show.
L.
O l.
O.
L.
He's trolling him.
Oh,
of course he is.
But Norton is awesome.
That is so funny.
I never,
I've never,
I haven't done that and I can't do it,
but I love reading people do it like Brendan Walsh does it.
Sometimes it makes me laugh and then yeah,
I'll show Mandy sometimes it says some crazy stuff.
If you ever follow him.
Who?
Joe,
Mandy Jo.
Mandy,
I'll follow.
Yeah,
he's hilarious.
Standup comic.
J.
O e m a n d y m e n d e m.
E.
N.
D.
E but at just the follow his Twitter.
It's great.
Okay.
Jose,
Mindy?
No,
no,
no tweets.
What is it?
Joe?
Joe.
Mandy.
M.
A n d e m.
Okay.
But he likes to,
you know,
re like retweet Joe from Brooklyn.
[inaudible] Nice.
Alright.
Oh follow.
There you go.
Joe.
You got props on the podcast.
So you got out.
It's very important to find good people to follow on Twitter.
Oh yeah.
I get,
I go through it again.
I get more information from Twitter than fucking anything I've ever done ever.
All Day.
I'm just getting all these fucking crazy links that I had about Michael Jackson
on Twitter.
Me Too.
Yeah.
ADDS to the addiction now.
It just makes it worse and worse.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it does.
It does.
Uh,
Matt Taibbi just made a,
an awesome blog post about that.
A Uc Davis pepper spray incident.
Fuck.
What do you think is going to happen with this thing?
Nick film,
if you had,
if you had a call,
a pepper spray,
the whole occupy thing,
this movement,
this,
there's government takeover momentum that's going on right now.
I'm an optimist.
My wife is cynical,
so like we will get in conversations like this.
I mean,
want to get better.
Your wife goes all Alex Jones.
Yeah.
She takes everything down a notch.
I mean like we have like our neighbors moving out.
The guy that lives like not the guy that I had got in trouble with on the
podcast like you got it lives on the other side of the wall from us.
Right.
You didn't number three
might as well fuck him too,
right?
She's just exactly,
he's actually a great DJ,
Dj,
Dj fashion did he?
A bit bit.
She's like,
our next week,
we're never going to have somebody as good as him again and that's all her,
you know,
nobody's even looked at it yet,
but she's already convinced that we're going to have a terrible neighbor.
This is going to be loud and he's the best it is.
I look at it like,
no,
we might get so many good.
What?
Why can't we just hope for that and hope that I have nice neighbors,
but I've had some issues with the neighbors in the past.
It's a,
it's a terrible thing,
man.
When you got somebody next to you,
that's it.
It's right next to him.
It's a very intense relationship.
I have a friend who's a dogs were poisoned by his neighbor.
Yeah,
moved to Portland.
It was up there and pull it out and is a dog was just,
you know,
running around barking every day and you know,
it was fucking new day for the dog dog and this guy complained and then the dogs
wound up poisoned.
I mean it's like they did,
he got didn't even drink.
I get in trouble.
Nope,
they couldn't prove it.
So I didn't do anything.
So I'd put,
I mean,
come on man,
poison your fucking dog.
And this is a guy that sleeps in a house,
you know,
right down the street from you and you have to think about that all the time.
That this is a guy that's willing to kill your dog,
your loved family member.
The New York Times had an article about barking dogs and neighbors and how that
relationship,
um,
affect,
you know,
the right way to deal with and they give like four different ways.
It's the right way to do it was pretty interesting because I go through that.
That was probably my neighbor.
Yeah,
I have,
I have issues like that,
you know,
but I don't mind when dogs bark.
It doesn't bother me.
But I don't want my dogs to fuck with other people.
That's what I'm worried about.
Anything is,
is there a dozen times that barking affects my dog or my like,
yes.
Like my dog.
Then it doesn't want to go take a shit where he would have been like 20 more
seconds,
but then the dog started barking and turn into a thing.
Well,
some people do leave their dogs out all night and never bring their dog again.
It's really kind of fucked up.
You'll be out at four o'clock in the morning.
You hear the dog barking,
constantly barking.
I'm uncomfortable.
Yeah,
exactly.
What's going on.
Okay.
Yes,
it's terrible.
Imagine,
imagine what they could say.
Just a roof and a lot of dogs get treated like shit.
I used to live next to this one lady who had these two dogs that she never
brought inside.
Even if it was pouring rain.
These fucking dogs just laid out there and soaked in the rain and my Nigga dog
gets treated like a prince.
Yeah.
My dogs have a full acre to run around and Oh my God,
I bought the spot.
One of the reasons why I bought it.
It's because there's this huge yard just for the dogs,
you know,
because I,
I feel terrible.
Okay.
Dot.
I c.
I have a,
a one dog as a Shibu.
He knew bulldog mix and the other one's a mastiff.
Oh Shit.
Huge dog.
Yeah.
Well,
he's a,
it's called a regency.
What they are is they're only about 140 pounds as opposed to like 200 pounds.
But they're,
they're much more agile.
They use him for like protection dogs and we had his dad on fear factor.
How old is he?
He's seven.
No,
six.
14 of my dogs.
Wait a minute.
How old do they live now?
He's only five.
I'm sorry.
He's five.
Um,
they probably live,
you know,
eight,
nine years if they're lucky because I have a French bulldog and I don't really
know their lifespan,
but he's awesome.
Those are great dogs.
Dogs live much longer to really,
big dogs have a real problem.
They don't live pay me.
Very rarely do they get to be like 10 or 11 like this really big mastiffs are
Saint Bernard's or something like that.
I mean it's like really big humans.
You know you see a guy like wilt Chamberlain,
those guys don't last man.
They don't live that long.
Big Seven foot dudes.
It's just that your body just can't,
I've got ahead of me.
Good luck lease you're thin.
You know it's healthier if you are taught to be thin when you the real issues
are with large big people because the amount of blood that your heart has to
pump through all that tissue to get yeah it becomes like a real issue.
I'm in the top 5% of height.
I that went to [inaudible] six four that's the top 5%.
Yeah there's,
I'm in the top 5% of America.
Do you think that that's going to be different in like another generation?
Cause I was just having a conversation with a friend of mine about this cause
he's a,
his wife has a big,
her brother is like a giant dude.
He's like six,
six and a,
their kid is fucking huge.
They have a kid,
it's only like two years old and this kid is giant man.
I mean you pick him up,
he's like a fucking bowling ball.
He's got these big ass hands and big feet and he runs into shit and falls down
and just gets ready.
He's like a tank man.
I mean I have little girls.
So watching a little girls is like a totally different thing.
It's like a giggly,
sweet sort of a laughing sort of baby time.
This motherfuckers running through walls,
I mean he's like a baby juggernaut.
Like you know,
you look at babies totally different when you see like a little stout,
two year old boy just smashed through a box of toys just smashed to him,
forearms and everything at toys are flying,
you know it.
I mean this guy is going to be a giant and I wonder with all the hormones in the
meat and all the fucking shit that people are eating now and all the speculation
as to why girls are getting their periods at age nine and shit.
Does that happen?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's way,
way younger than ever before.
And a lot of people speculate.
It's,
you know,
from eating processed food that has hormones in it and these hormones stimulate
our hormones and make us,
uh,
they may make us hit puberty faster,
make us bigger.
I wonder what people are going to be like in another generation with all this
shit.
You know,
I mean it,
it,
it might just be a normal thing for people to be six foot four,
six foot five.
I hope it's so you have fun,
don't you?
Wouldn't you rather be the stand out?
But then the people that we're going to stand out,
we'll just be that much taller.
Right.
But then,
you know,
cause it really,
you don't really never realize it.
Once I see somebody taller than me,
it blows my mind and I,
that's the only person I can look at because,
well,
what is it like when you go to like a basketball game?
You see those giant dudes?
Yeah.
Bit hanging out around Hollywood.
You know,
like at party,
usually in the tallest guy at a party.
You never go.
One guy might come into a party that's taller than me and then I can't talk to
him.
I didn't want to be seen next to him.
Do you guys,
you have an issue with that?
Yeah cause he,
it sometimes it's fun to be the tallest person so you get upset if another
person comes in,
that's all you have,
Sun come on.
It's when it's just one of those things where you,
when you talk to people and you look up at him,
you don't really realize it and then all of a sudden you're looking up at
somebody.
It's like,
oh my,
well that's
like a weird perspective to me when I find someone shorter than me because I'm
five,
eight,
you know,
I'm not very tall.
So if I run into someone who's like five,
five or five for wireless is actually smart,
smarter than me.
That's odd.
You know like Brad when Brad Williams comes around,
no,
like regular size,
bad Williams.
And I had the funniest first run and where he was on stage to the laugh factory
and it's closed on this great joke where he's like,
he gets a really great student.
Like I'm probably standing ovation about like how he can't jerk off unless he's
sitting down because it's torse.
His arms are like shorter than his torso.
And that's what,
and so I went up and I said,
the thing about chat is,
is that he also can't jerk me off unless he's standing up Brad and then no.
Then he goes from the back of the room.
Fuck you Rick.
Because I said Chad,
is that guy funny?
Yeah.
He's funny.
He's a boy,
right?
What's that?
Carl's been,
see his boy.
It doesn't the uh,
oh yeah,
dude,
I guess I don't even think about that.
I think he was on a show.
Yeah.
Yeah,
it was on all the time.
I kind of like,
yeah,
like with Chewy is on Chelsea lately.
Julie,
the little guy on Chelsea.
I haven't seen him.
I thought you were thinking when I hear chew or think a truly from the comedy
store.
No,
no,
no.
It's not a big Mexican at all.
Did you hear about the Chewy,
the guy that was like chewy that I was in Austin Powers?
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
He didn't murder.
He took part in a gang rape.
No,
the guy in jail that he was in the murder.
The guy in jail.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He did.
He murder the guy in the sky in Austin Powers the Asian guy that played like
the,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
The Asian Guy,
Austin Powers was a guy named Joseph who was actually a famous for fighting in
the UFC and getting punched in the balls.
He fought a dude named Keith Hackney and Keith Hackney got him down in side
control and Joe Sohn held onto a headlock.
And Keith Hackney just punched him in the balls over and over and over.
And Keith Agni can punch man.
So this isn't like a little baby punches.
He's like furious blast to the Gonads,
you know,
wearing a crushing them,
wearing a cup or not wearing a cop.
I don't give a fuck.
He's getting punished.
Where was he wearing a cup?
I believe you was,
but I think still got that.
It hurts.
Even when a cup on man,
it fucking hurts.
And this guy just wailing on his balls.
So that's how he became famous and apparently he got arrested for something else
and when they ran his DNA,
it matched up with a rape case that they had from the 1990s where a bunch of
guys had gang raped this chick and then just like left her for dead.
And so they're all fucked now.
They're all in jail.
The the people that did it with him,
I think
that's crazy to me when the,
when DNA comes out and then it changes cases.
So stuff is getting salt now that would have never been
or the worst is when people you find out they were in jail for nothing
innocent.
You know,
this such sad.
They just opened up that one case that I famous actors with Christopher Walken
was Natalie Wood.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
You know the Natalie Wood case?
Yeah,
I've heard about the pilot said that he believes that.
Was it Robert Wagner?
Yeah.
It wasn't as though it was something about how she,
some of the pilots that are there,
the guy on the boat,
right said,
shouldn't we go find her?
And he said,
no,
she'll be fine.
Well,
the,
whoever the the pilot is or the,
uh,
the,
not pilot,
captain of the boat,
the captain,
the boat is now coming out and saying that he is,
uh,
that he's responsible and that he heard pounding and then it stopped.
And then the woman was in the water after that.
I don't know man.
It's just weird now just coming out like he was on NBC like the early morning
Shit,
like not the today show maybe was the today show.
And the guy asked him like seven times.
The interview is actually really weird.
He asked him like seven times,
like,
why now?
What's different now than it was long time and the guy would not answer the
question.
And in one point you would just say,
well,
I said everything in the book that I just told them that,
you know,
who has a book?
And it was,
it was kind of like selling a book.
But why are they opening up like,
what is he saying different,
you know,
like it,
it was a weird interview of you Google a bag somewhere.
I don't know where it,
Natalie would may have struggled for hours before she died.
And what's with Christopher Walken being involved?
He was hanging out there.
Yeah,
I dunno.
He had some good coke.
They were on a boat.
This guy.
Wow.
This guy is selling a really sensationalist book.
She,
she might have floated alive and dark water for hours.
Why Robert Wagner allegedly stalled rescue efforts.
Wow.
This is weird.
Well,
if this is true,
this guy who's the captain,
that guy should go to jail because you held this information back for all these
years.
You fuckhead you allow this piece of shit.
If this guy,
if Robert Ragnar,
well he did kill Natalie Wood.
I don't know the seat.
I don't know if he's saying anything different than he was back then.
Now I think there's more to it.
Yeah,
I think he,
what he's saying is I saying the same shit that I was a long time ago.
They're just listening now.
You know,
before they didn't,
whoever wasn't saying was,
well look,
I only seen him now.
He just revealed that would,
and Wagner had been arguing intensely before she went missing.
Damn.
Imagine if a batch of Robert why and it just killed her and all these jails.
No,
he got off.
Oh yeah man.
He went on to do TV show.
I think they wrote it as suicide.
No.
Well they shoot,
they ruled.
It was an accident and he went on to do TV shows.
Could you imagine if it turns out that he really murdered her and then he went
on to just do all this other shit and he thought it was over and he sees that
will come out.
He's like,
ah,
so crazy as this 2011 I'm looking at photos of her and him online,
you know,
2011 I'm looking at celebrity justice on TMZ and it's like,
it's coming back to get them.
That's dark shit,
man.
If he really killed her,
it would be really fascinating to watch that trial and to see his eyes,
to see,
you know,
to see how much of it,
the fact that we can do that now we actually watch,
you know,
what man things and fucking 27 years ago,
which is what this was from or is that what it was?
It might've been more,
yeah.
Oh,
prosecutors would have had to file the charges 27 years ago.
Jesus Christ.
So I don't know when this actually happened.
The Da says that short of a confession,
they're not going to go after it,
but the,
um,
the idea that they get grabbed him and catch him after all these years and put
him in a trial,
that would be fascinating to see his eyes.
Do you think even if he did it,
he think even allows himself to remember,
fuck yeah,
he thinks about it every day.
Do you think so that's his to the plotter lying about it so much.
He probably believes a little bit in his head.
He can't quite remember what the truth is or,
you know,
that's what I think.
Yeah.
30 years ago.
That's what it was.
I mean,
I can relate with him with what happened with the SNL tweet with Brendan 19.
Yeah.
I start believing now that I have this theory about a memory that uh,
any memory more than seven years old,
it's very faulty because every cell in the body is replaced every seven years,
every seven years.
Every single individual cell in your body is duplicated except for your neurons.
The neurons you keep for life,
but you were cells rejuvenate every seven years.
So we don't really know exactly where memory is captain.
There is some speculation that maybe it's kept in the neurons,
but if it's not and it's kept in the cells,
how crazy would it be if your cells just hand down your new self,
like a bunch of files.
Like here's some stuff we remember,
uh,
this fucked up when we were kids and you fell on a bike when you're 70 broke
your arm.
But you know,
I fell off the monkey bars when I was seven at snapped my arms sideways.
I have virtually no memory of it.
I know my mom has photos of it.
And I could see my arm in a cast and I could see a sad look on my face.
But other than that,
that that memory doesn't exist.
It only exists if I keep refreshing it,
if I keep adding to us biggest fears.
When I was younger,
it's not copy and pasting.
Yeah,
mine too.
And then when it happened,
I was like,
whoa.
You know,
cause I used to always fall down,
so I broke my leg,
but I really didn't break my leg.
So then when I said I broke my arm,
my parents didn't think I broke my arm.
And then I picked it up and it was a fucking pretzel.
I mean it was bent at the forearm.
I fell off a monkey bar.
On one hand I fell off the monkey bars and cut my chin open.
Ooh.
Yeah,
I did that too.
I've got a bunch of those days.
You didn't do any of that?
No.
Monkey bars me.
You a little.
What'd you do it just hide.
No,
I did all that.
I just never got hurt.
Never broke anything.
You never,
you never pushed it to the limit to limit?
No.
Take it to the,
what is it about the 1980s and then it comes in with a voiceover?
When I play on the monkey bars,
go all the way.
I go sweaty hands.
All right.
I think this fucking shows over.
Let's bring this bitch home.
Thank you Nick Dune for coming on the show.
Me.
Please follow him on Twitter.
It's his name and I.
He's a fine young man.
Perhaps you should have a podcast of your own.
Nick's doing.
Have you considered it?
I have considered it.
I thought you'd have some kind of always that sort of doing a live talk show.
Right?
What do you do that at UCB?
Once a month.
It's like a light,
like a late night next December 8th as a record them.
Yeah.
We're taping and I'm going to try and sell it eventually as a talk show.
Yeah,
but for now it's just fun.
It's a sort of theme to it or theme is I come out as a host as me and then I
interviewed people from my life,
but it's comedic actors playing.
So like my first show,
I interviewed the girl,
I lost my virginity to this girl named Shannon Woodward played her and then I
interviewed the guy that was like my neighbor football star that was like way
better than me.
Is this,
um,
and then I just go down or do you like,
yeah,
we scripted out,
but then we improv it kind of,
you kind of know where to go.
Oh that's kind of the way it goes is I get taken like this next one's going to
be my birthday show,
so it's all going to be birthday themed.
But emotionally I'd go on a roller coaster to the show and like get really down
because the girl comes out.
Those my,
that I lost memory you needed to and she doesn't want to be with me anymore.
But I thought that if you saw that I had a talk show,
things would change.
And you know,
that's funny.
Have you ever thought about doing a podcast?
Yeah,
I have.
I just went,
you know,
there's so many of them that already have so much steam.
I would want to do something.
It doesn't matter man.
Listen,
just do one.
Do it.
Good people find it.
It's that simple.
One thing I'm scared of is the things that I say because like now should be a
little bit,
you're a little wacky with that.
I don't mean to be,
and then I get and then it,
you know?
Yeah.
Just part of being a comic,
you know,
you have unfiltered yeah and back to bite me.
And those,
those ideas that produce like a big reaction become valuable.
Your memories of someone doing something fucked up.
Those are valuable.
And also what you say like about um,
you know,
like not when you say your hotel room,
like those are just things I don't think about it.
You should,
if you're staying in Austin,
you say what hotel you're on and then somebody gets your fucking hotel room and
just knocks on it.
Duct tapes,
your face.
It makes one of those videos when they were going to pay behind 400 bucks or
like that website crashing.
You know?
Like if you say something about somebody you mean like again,
[inaudible] dot com [inaudible] dot com is cool.
That's a good thing.
That's a good thing,
but what if you say something bad about something,
an accident.
Oh yeah,
it's true.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You just have to be careful.
You do.
I mean,
right now,
500,000 people are listening to everything.
You say so many shit.
I wish I could go back on trust like what?
I don't know.
Anyway,
thank you to the fleshlight for sponsoring the podcast.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight,
you get 15% off the number one sex toy from Matt and Nick Dune.
I'll be providing you with a free one before you leave the same thing.
Great.
I'm sure you're excited about this.
Go to Joe Rogan dot neck.
Click the link.
Enter in the and Brogan.
Get yourself some money off and a on it.com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain new mood,
um,
and a shroom tech sport.
And what's really important about this Alpha brain stuff and there's a lot of
controversy.
One of the most important things is you get your money back free,
100% money back guarantee.
You don't even have to return the product.
You know,
if you take it within the,
it's like 30 days or whatever the hell it is,
or one dose 30 pills,
take it.
You don't like it,
send it back.
Okay.
You get your money.
It's that simple because,
um,
you don't have it send it back.
So just take the product.
I'm upset about not to send it back.
Right.
Did I say send it back,
send it in that you want it,
whatever you don't have.
I'm not good at commercials.
All right.
That's why people say why these commercials so long because they're not really
commercials.
I mean they are,
I have to get some information across,
but I don't want to say something that sounds completely and totally insincere.
I've heard those and I don't like him.
I find them offensive.
You know what else I don't like?
I don't know.
Like when somebody reads off cue cards,
I don't like it.
I don't like it when they do it during sporting events.
I don't like when they do it during presidential speeches to mind.
I don't mind it SEL or um,
you know,
if you got to look down at your notes,
look down at your notes,
man.
Be Real with me.
You fuck,
listen,
go out there and fucking make it happen.
Ladies and Gentlemen,
this is Lee Zoe bringing the energy back.
This is now.
We love you.
All right,
we'll see you guys tomorrow.
We're going to be at the Ice House for a very special day before thanksgiving.
Show all my Jesus Christ who's going to be on the show.
You ask why none other than Joey Coco Diaz,
while none of them.
Then Brian Red Ban Steevo from Jackass
Divo from jackass and a whole bunch of surprises and a whole bunch of surprises.
All of our friends who were in town,
you know,
a lot of comics are in town for the holiday weekend.
Last week,
Neal Brennan,
Brennan just stop by.
Yeah.
And we're also going to do a podcast with Joey Diaz.
Uh,
we'll do a Joe Rogan experience podcast tomorrow before the shows,
and then we're also going to just branch out into one of our new podcast that
we're doing called the ice house chronicles.
To find the icehouse chronicles,
you got to go to desk squad on Itunes to subscribe to death squad.
And there's a bunch of great podcasts are on desk.
We'll the Sam triply naughty shows on death squad,
Thomson [inaudible] and Christina Palicki.
They have their podcast is called your mom's house.
That's also on death squad.
Um,
we've got,
uh,
Brendan Walsh.
She was fucking hilarious.
Has the bone zone.
There's a lot of podcasts,
but it's Brendan Walsh is podcast.
It's awesome.
Yeah.
So,
but the latest one that we're doing,
it's called the ice house chronicles.
And it literally is all the funniest people we know in a comedy club where we
have a podcast studio set up.
It's amazing.
So subscribe to that and,
uh,
that's it.
You dirty freaks,
New Year's Eve,
Melrose Improv in Hollywood.
We'll see you there.
See you guys soon.
All right,
we love you.
Bye.
Big Kiss.